трансляцію скоро будемо запускати
та колеги також важлива організаційний
момент що
підтримки Євросоюзу його країн-членів
зокрема Німеччини Фінляндії Естонії та
Польщі за підтримки міжнародних
організацій таких як jz та інших за
сприяння Міністерства освіти і науки
України федерації роботодавців І власне
весь контент який реалізується в рамках
тренінгів які ви берете участь в рамках
сьогоднішнього всеукраїнського
конференції він є відповідальністю
спікерів його авторів і не може бути
презентоване або зрозумілий як позиція
Європейського Союзу ну власне Ми готові
починати І я радий вітати всіх хто з
нами наживо наших спікерів наших
учасників тих хто чується з нами в
онлайн-трансляцію так чується з нами
момент трансляції тож Всім доброго дня
давайте поаплодуємо один одного
І звісно Дякуємо збройним силам нашим за
те що ми маємо нагоду зустрічатися
наживо маємо нагоду проводити такі
заходи це є найважливішим для нас усіх і
безпека звісно я найважливішим нашим
фактором тож ми сподіваємося і віримо в
ЗСУ в те що все буде спокійно чудово на
випадок повітряних трьох звісно Ми
мусимо тому перейти вкриття але віримо
що все буде класно Отже колеги я радий
вітати усіх нас на всеукраїнській
конференції професійна орієнтація
успішної практики та нові виклики Мене
звати Роман Куриленко Я є керівником
центру кар'єри книг імені Тараса
Шевченка буду сьогоднішнім модератором
цього заходу так І власне ми готові Вже
розпочинати Я вдячний також партнерам
які сьогодні будуть і нашими спікерами в
тому числі і запрошую знову ж таки
учасників підключатися до онлайну адже
при цьому Ми в гібридному форматі щоб
всі-всі-всі мали доступ до тієї
конференції до того матеріалу яким
будемо сьогодні слухати презентувати
обговорювати і власне хочу до вітального
слова до такого відкриття запросити пані
генерального директора директорату
професійної освіти міністерства та науки
України пані Ірина
топ з нами в залі і обов'язково тих хто
доєднався до нас через онлайн-трансляцію
дійсно не просто сьогодні проводити
заходи наживо але я захоплююсь також
всіма колегами які
незважаючи на погану погоду сніг дощ
ракетні обстріли все ж таки доїхали
сьогодні присутні тут сподіваємося що
якнайшвидше припиниться весь той жах і
ми зможемо вже зробити такий величезний
форум на декілька сот осіб для того щоб
всі бажаючі змогли долучитися але
сьогодні працюємо в такому гібридному
змішаному форматі і питання яке Ми
сьогодні хочемо з вами обговорити
презентувати кращі практики це питання
професійної орієнтації власне півтора
місяці тому ми з вами говорили про
кар'єрне консультування про те як
важливо
молоді особі та й взагалі кожному
допомагати у професійному розвитку
кар'єрному розвитку Але сьогодні ми
будемо говорити про те як важливо
правильно зробити вибір професії так що
що потрібно робити для того щоб
допомогти кожній маленький особистості
пізнати цей світ світ професій і обрати
ту яка найкраще для себе я перш за все
хочу передати велике вітання від
міністра освіти і науки Сергія шкарлика
вчора на засіданні колеги ми
ухвалили схвалили концептуальні засади
модернізації подальшого розвитку системи
професійної освіти саме з акцентом на ті
наслідки які спричинила на сьогодні
війна тому що Зрозуміло що сьогодні
потрібно дуже швидко реагувати на
потреби ринку праці ми маємо велику
кількість людей які переїхали і сьогодні
потребують термінового перенавчання і
пошуку нового робочого місця в нас є
величезне питання щодо
військовослужбовців які зазнали
інвалідності або на сьогодні виходять
після служби в Збройних Силах і теж
потребують відповідної підтримки у
здобутті професії самореалізації в
цивільному житті і саме ці питання
розглядалися Вчора на колегії ми оновили
бачення майбутньої професійної освіти
сподіваємося що як найближче це буде
певний Урядовий документ так наша
оновлена концепція але
одне з ключових питань так залишається
професійна орієнтація тому я щиро вітаю
всіх вас я знаю що нам є що презентувати
за останні чотири роки Ми багато
попрацювали над тим щоб професійна
орієнтація стала краще в нас ще багато
чого є зробити і дізнатися і навчитися
тому Бажаю всім сьогодні плідної роботи
дякую пані Ірино
А І дійсно під час нашої конференції ми
і презентуємо те що вже готова до
впровадження і буде працювати і працює
вже на базі кращих практик ми з вами
випрацюємо нові інструменти нові ідеї до
обговорення і впровадження вже ваших
тактиках тому дійсно є чудова наша
нагода зустрітися всім разом на Живучи в
онлайні До речі вже навіть в онлайні нас
близько 50 учасників тож уже загалом нас
більше сотні на зв'язку ну а зараз саме
час подякувати за дуже гостинний прийом
Рівненщині за чудові умови проживання за
ці можливості знову ж таки проведення І
власне дуже дякуємо за це Рівненщині і
зараз до вітального слова Хотів би
запросити пана Віталія Коваля у голову
Рівненської обласної військової
адміністрації
Доброго дня друзі однодумці раді вітати
вас на Рівненщині тому що для нас
сьогодні переосмислення багатьох
моментів наступило тому що те що до 24
лютого здавалось важливим але не
нагальним сьогодні стало і нагальним і
важливим і таких процесів в нашому житті
дуже багато
те що ми розуміли що дуже важливо Це
професійна орієнтація і просто освіта
сьогодні для нас стало Мабуть
пріоритетом
№1 я не побоюсь цього слова тому що
ми з вами всі усвідомили одну річ
зайняті руки ніколи не впустяться і це
треба розуміти і усвідомлювати на рівні
ДНК що ці зайняті руки вони крім того що
дають
впевненість в завтрашньому дні вони
сьогодні наближають перемогу і бажано
щоб ці руки були золотими і золотими
Вони стають тоді коли людина по своїй
навичці по своєму характеру обрала фах
ми з вами знаємо що
до 15 разів людина буде змінювати
найближчим часом рід занять не просто
місце роботи а рід занять і це
статистика світова Дослідження які
проведені глибоко тому що ми з вами
перейшли в нову реальність яка
називається
мінливе планування і важко сказати що
буде
післязавтра тому що у нас сьогодні
мінливо буде тривога не буде тривога але
чітко його усвідомлення буде перемога А
щоб вона була швидше потрібно кожному на
своєму місці роботи те що він може на
110%. і друзі Ви саме сьогодні
наближаєте перемогу тому що ви
закладаєте ті підмурки і
цю структуру Перемоги з усвідомленням
важливий момент військово-промисловий
комплекс здається де профтехосвіта де
військово-промисловий комплекс А це
брати близнюки сьогодні тому що ми
знаємо приклади на жаль всіх воїн до
сьогодні саме ті країни які швидко
орієнтувалися і розгорнули виробництво в
тилу перемогли битви виграють полководці
а війни виграють економіки економіка не
може бути без
професійно-технічної освіти без фаху і
без оцих золотих рук які ніколи не
впустяться тому сьогодні на нас з вами
велика відповідальність ми не просто
збираємося в такому крузі ми дійсно
маємо напрацювати ті найшвидші практики
ті найефективніші рішення щоб наші діти
наші дорослі особливо наші вимушено
переміщення особи і
військові які повернеться з фронту щоб
вони зайняли свої руки а ці роки
наступну перемогу не секрет що перемога
буде не з одного етапу перше - це
очищення нашої рідної землі від тих небі
а другий етап - це обрати велику мету і
ця мета має бути
Україна має стати центром Східної Європи
спочатку Східної Європи тому що не можна
лякати всю Європу одразу так і
цей центр Східної Європи який буде
сьогодні драйвером росту цілого регіону
Це більше ніж країна це той феномен коли
до нас вам будуть приїжджати отримати
нові практики і все ж таки зрозуміти в
чому феномен українців де це ДНК
перемоги А ДНК Перемоги дуже просте
30 років Ми шукали національну ідею вона
є робить Те що можеш там де ти є І от я
хочу закликати вас переосмислити
те Чим ви займаєтесь ви сьогодні не
бажаєте перемогу і це дуже важливо
після вашого усвідомлення
ви побачите як змінюється навіть ваш
робочий день і
простір навколо вас тому що сьогодні ви
робите великі справи Ви дійсно створюєте
нову країну яка базується на мабуть
найкращих українських якостях на
працелюбності і на готовності до
самопожества самопожертви заради країни
і це самопожертва коли є результативною
ефективною
вона перетворюється на
цей момент коли ми говоримо не вмирати
за Україну А коли ми говоримо перемагати
за Україну а перемога вона багатогранна
і на різних фронтах тому на
освітянському фронті на фронті
зайнятості на вас велика Надія цей
посили я вам даю і Дозвольте ще декілька
таких моментів
загальнонаціональних сказати ми з вами
бачимо процес реформування служби
зайнятості І от з Петром Миколайовичем
На минулому тижні мали розширену нараду
з центром зайнятості служби зайнятості
центральної і ми розуміємо що цей
переформат служби зайнятості Він дуже
дотичний до профтехосвіти і вам
доведеться підхопити багато що з
функціоналу служби зайнятості і
надихнути нове життя
Сьогодні принцип вчитись протягом життя
Він має стати наріжним і золотий
трикутник освіта бізнес і
економіка Він має ну працювати в одній
звязь тому що ми маємо готувати тих
спеціалістів які потребує бізнес
у нас в Рівному створено така платформа
Дякую до речі нашому освітньому корпусу
і Петро Миколайовичу всім дівчатам і
хлопцям які зайняті в цьому процесі
Рівне warcup це та платформа яка дає
результат
що вона собою являється платформа до
якої вже підключено 989 підприємств які
нам дають реальну свою потребу в
робочих руках
в напрямках професії і Ми для них
регіональне замовлення змінюємо і в нас
сьогодні регіональне замовлення не копій
паст в нас регіональне замовлення - це
передовий досвід і це дійсно те що дає
результат для мене показником є те що
42% випускників шкіл ідуть проти це один
з найвищих показників в Україні і це ще
не бажаний показник якось Скандинавії
75%, але він вже реальний і дає
результат
це означає що ми на правильному шляху
потрібно масштабувати цей успіх на іншій
області тому що не час сьогодні щось
гарне зробити замкнутись собі А час
сьогодні мастурбувати далі і особливо
підтримку того що вам настанову даю
особливо вчитись колег тому що ми
думаємо що ми самі круті про в техосвіті
а я думаю що наші колеги можуть з нами
багато з чим поділитись і це буде
правильний обмін досить саме для таких
обмінів ми тут зустрічаємось Тому я
бажаю щиро сьогодні такого натхненного і
продуктивного вам спілкування щоб ви
звідси поїхали знову Ми ідеями в
реалізували ці ідеї і щоб сьогодні тут
українська перемога стала ще на один
метр ближче а вона такими речами і
наближається тому з Вірою у вас з вірою
в профтехосвіту з великим очікуванням до
цього напрямку і з Вірою Україну Слава
Україні Героям слава
Дякую пане Вітаю Дякую за ці важливі
слова і дійсно нам з вами безпосередньо
нашим учням випускникам країни
підтримувати зараз країну відбудовувати
і розбудовувати так і ми не зупиняємося
навіть В умовах воєнного стану тих
екстремальних умовах що створили нам
терористи Так ми не зупиняємося Ми
продовжуємо створювати нові проекти Ми
продовжуємо свою роботу Ми продовжуємо
генерувати ідеї створювати якісних
спеціалістів То є наша велика мета
робота і наш план на подальший
найближчий час на нашому майбутнє так А
ми з вами колеги продовжуємо і разом з
нами на зв'язку в онлайн форматі
директор програми UFO Skills Міхаель
Пауло як я і казав як я казав наша
програма реалізується за підтримки
міжнародних партнерів Євросоюзу зокрема
польських організацій польського фонду
тож запрошую до слова зараз з п
колеги я буду допомагати перекладати
виступ нашого пана Міхаеля А Соломія
Stage is yours Welcome
what to Say my Cooper
перш за все Я вітаю наших спікерів пана
Віталія Коваля Ірина Шумик та пана Петра
корчевського
Я дуже радий що ми маємо нагоду
зустрітися наживо сьогодні
і 6 Ukraine
depocation and
Я дуже пишаюся тим і радий бачити
скільки людей залучено до сектору
професійного світу в Україні
а ми всі розуміємо що наші плани наша
реальність змінюються зокрема і ринок
праці
компанія релакується та зростає відсоток
тих хто зараз Втратив роботу
і ми маємо дати найкращі можливості
найкраще практики для наших учнів
бо ти степу теж
які навички знадобляться де їм шукати
роботу та які можливо сценарії для їх
успішного працевлаштування і ухва скилдс
Project to
orientations
а і фоскілс має на меті надати нові
знання нові практики для центрів кар'єри
закладів професійно-технічної освіти
і за підтримки Міністерства освіти та
науки України цей проект реалізується
прямо зараз
і дуже радий що Рівненська область
Рівненщина також бере участь і активно
залучено до цього проекту
Modern
Wanted
А протягом 4 місяців ми провели понад 33
тренінгів до яких долучилися загалом
понад 1000 студентів та учнів які
охопили більше 50 закладів професійної
та професійно-технічної освіти
а в складні для України часи європейські
партнери завжди поруч з вами зокрема
Німеччина Естонія Польща та інші країни
активно долучаються до розвитку
компетенції наших та наших учнів
має
дизайн forted
зовсім нещодавно Німеччина прийшла з
новим запитом до організації jz створити
ще один проект спільно з міністерством
освіти та науки України
Ukraine ми готові навчати майбутніх і
теперішніх професіоналів фахівців
навички яких будуть критично важливими
для відбудови і подальшої розбудови
нашої країни
і кар'єрний консультування в цьому
аспекті теж є надзвичайно важливим тож
вдячний вам за вашу роботу і залученість
тож Дякуємо пану Міхаелю і продовжуємо
працювати зараз хотів би до першого
вітального слова запросити пана Петра
корчевського директора Департаменту
освіти та науки Рівненської Обласної
Державної адміністрації то пане Петро
вам слово вітаю
мікрофон мене не затримує насправді мені
приємно що ми завершуємо цей фінансовий
рік власне таким заходом в сфері
професійної освіти Я думаю що зі слів
Голови адміністрації вам стало зрозуміло
що ви знаходитеся в столиці професійної
освіти Я не боюся цих пафосних слів
завжди кажу що дуже складно дуже легко
завойовувати але дуже складно утримувати
власними зараз живемо в такому форматі
коли всі наші задекларовані дії нам
треба кожного разу утримувати ми
працюємо з кожною дитиною з кожним
бізнесом з кожним прилакованим бізнесом
у нас майданчик
почули яка кількість роботодавців тобто
з кожним необхідно пропрацювати аби
створити їм комфортні умови аби
Рівненщина стала інвестиційно
привабливою це ключовий вислів над яким
працюють усі без винятку і головою
поставлені завдання що тільки
сплачені податки дають можливість нам
взагалі щось розвивати і Якщо раптом
хтось не планував у рік коли ми маємо
війну і збройна агресію Росії не буде
ніхто відкривати навчально-практичний
центр Ми ламаємо стереотипи війна - це
можливість він на це можливості Ми
повинні демонструвати дітям що життя
триває що освітнє середовище повинно
бути іншим і новаційним воно повинно
бути абсолютно
готовим готувати фахівців високого рівня
Ми настільки змінюємо освітнє середовище
щоб бізнес не завжди готовий приймати
наших учнів які працюють на
високотехнологічному обладнанні але і
тут ми повинні не боятися говорити що ми
законодавці моди у сфері формування
трудового потенціалу Ми повинні
працювати
найнасучаснішому обладнанні Ми повинні
показу сказати про технології Ми повинні
говорити яким повинен бути сервіс
обслуговування сфери професійної освіти
це повсюди як я завжди кажу від зачісок
до всього що смачно приготовлені власне
хотілося щоб ми з вами поділилися тим як
же ж привабити учня у заклад професійної
освіти про тупори профорієнтація яка має
стати ключовою комунікаційною стратегією
Бо
42%, коли ми є Ніна іларіонов коли ми
однієї ночі писали стратегію і коли ми
декларували про 40% всі там махали і
мені показували біля Виска що 40%
охопити професійної освіти ну це те саме
що
стрибнути з висоти 50 м і сподіватися
вижити я вам скажу що складно але
можливо кожен із нас кожної своєї дії
повинен переконувати кожну людину що
бути
майстром своєї справи Це престижно бути
випускником закладу професійної освіти
це достойно Якщо ми прийдемо цей етап то
не заграми тих 75% де в Скандинавії
хочуть зробити професійну освіту на
рівні базової освіти а дальше кожен має
собі будувати власну освітню і успішну
траєкторію Я би хотів щоб ви отримали
хороші спілкування один з одним бо не
так часто оцей період часу нам
приходиться бачитися Face to Face я
дякую ювестіл Дякую Міхаелю за ті
ініціативи Які ми які вони підтримують
Дякую всім чотирьом країнам партнерам
цього проекту тому що Кожен робить свою
справу Я знаю що поляки найперші
відгукнулися на те що Ну у війну треба
все-таки щось робити Я сподіваюся на
еміс від естонців я сподіваюся на
стандарти зрозумілі на
зрозумілістандарти від фінів і я
сподіваюся на
перший платників податків в основному
від Країни Німеччини і дуже би хотілося
щоб Україна цим скористалася сповна щоб
ми розуміли що навчання упродовж життя
це не пусті слова Ми повинні з вами бути
готові будь-яку людину яка йде по
вулицях раптом сумнівається що вона щось
не те робить швиденько перенавчити щоб
вона була успішною що вона розуміла що
вона в цій країні має шанс на життя і ще
ключове пам'ятаємо що дуже Багато наших
випускників цей учнів які навчаються
вони за кордоном дуже багато наших
майстрів виробничого навчання і
викладачів вони долучаються до нас
офлайн нам обов'язково їх треба
повернути в Україну ми їх можемо
повернути тільки тим що А ми про них не
забули ми з ними на постійному зв'язку і
Ми створюємо такі можливості щоб вони
сюди повернулися нам надзвичайно треба
майстри виробничого навчання нам
надзвичайно треба переконати і уряд в
тому числі що оплата праці майстра
виробничого навчання повинна бути
абсолютно іншою достойною аби він мі
представити всі свої лайфхаки зараз
молоді людині молоді молода людина має
достатньо інформації яку вона може
черпати з
інформаційного простору але вона хоче
живого майстра який руками може
продемонструвати як це робити як це
виглядає В кінцевому результаті і
тішитися з результату своєї праці я вам
дякую за те що ви подавали відстані Я
сподіваюся що це
піде на користь всім нам Я теж готовий
отримати від вас зворотний зв'язок
почути про кращі ваші практики ми усі
єдина сім'я і ви знаєте що той
слоган який свого часу я почав
транслювати все буде ПТО так і є на
Рівненщині вже є все каталог дякую дякую
вам пане Петре
І дійсно Ми дуже вдячні всім
країнам-партнерам Євросоюзу загалом та
країнам-партнерам програми іофосхіллса -
це Німеччина Фінляндія Польща та Естонія
які активно залучаються до проекту своїм
ділиться своїм досвідом підтримують наші
ініціативи тож дуже вдячні самій
програмі і країнам-партнерам зокрема за
те що під час війни нашого навчання і
розвиток і роботи не лише продовжується
Вони мають нові вектори вони набувають
нового актуального з місця Перепрошую і
Ми продовжуємо розвивати нашу
професійно-технічну освіту саме в
Україні саме для наших здобувачів Отже
колеги Продовжуємо роботу на нашій
конференції І власне як вже анонсували
наші шановні спікери А у нас заплановано
аналіз багатьох проектів Що вже в роботі
і зокрема про те які досягнення вже були
здобуті так які виклики перед нами і як
їх ми їх будемо долати хочу запросити до
слова пані Ірину шумі генерального
директорку директора та професійного
освіти міністерства та освіти і науки
України пані Ірина запрошує вас мабуть
вам пояснюється
Ми вже звикли працювати
будь-де І будь-як чи то чи то інколи
пункту незламності на автозаправці чи то
наприклад я просто захоплююсь тими
викладачами і вчителями які реально
кидають все йдуть на автозаправки або
спускаються десь ну тут це просто де
видаєшся але заняття має відбутися і не
знаю чи радіють тому Наші учні
але власне У нас свій героїзм друзі Ми
нещодавно з вами зустрічалися дійсно
обговорювали певні напрямки якраз
кар'єрного консультування і кар'єрне
консультування професійного орієнтація
вони між собою дуже близькі і
взаємопов'язані як правило таке блоком
реалізовуються але все ж таки сьогодні
трошки
оповім таку загальну картину власне про
професійну орієнтацію як Міністерство
освіти і науки звичайно з фокусом на
професійну освіту
яких Нам вдалося заходів вжити що
здалося реалізувати які проекти І власне
потім далі Мої колеги вже про ці проекти
розкажуть більш детальніше ну перш за
все
у мене з презентацією сьогодні не це але
і таке буває ми її розмістимо потім на
сайті Міністерства можна буде
ознайомитися щодо організації освітнього
процесу в нас 225 000 здобувачів освіти
приступили до навчання цього року і
варто зауважити що це 81 і три десятих
тисячі Це новий прийом це нові здобувачі
це те чого всі власне боялися тому що
всі думали що цього року взагалі буде
складно когось набрати в систему
професійної освіти але як виявилося
навіть ранній випуск закладу освіти не
лякає наших здобувачів вони готові не
тільки здобувати професію а потім і
батьківщинуйте захищати ну і тут важливі
цифри 91% як це виконання регіонального
замовлення 74% виконання державного
замовлення звичайно якщо говорити про
державний замовлення трошки складнувато
але ви знаєте що там і без того професії
які не користуються особливою
популярністю саме тому вони отримують
відповідно підтримку з держави але те що
стосується регіонального замовлення
дійсно дуже помітна ця тенденція
перегляду і вже актуалізації відповідно
професії з якими формуються регіональне
замовлення
відповідно до того яким є на сьогодні
ринок праці і власне наші такі
мікропроекти невеличкі досягнення
цього року за підтримки програми її
форшкілс ми надзвичайно вдячні цей рік
незважаючи на війну був дуже
продуктивний було
запущено і реалізовано дві промокомпанії
така основна генеральна про
вісьмох фахівців спеціалістів
і вона мала назву все працює завдяки нам
ми власне хотіли показати наскільки
професіонали важливі в нашому
повсякденному житті що раніше здавалося
нормальними Сьогодні ми всі знаємо як
енергетики рятують кожен наш день
надаючи нам можливість приготувати їжу
чи
скористатися Здавалося б такими вже
звичними для нас душем та чи чи взагалі
іншими зручностями і друга промокомпанії
вона була трошки вужча трошки така більш
націлена на конкретний результат це
стосовно
професійної орієнтації вже перед вступом
та і промоції вступу до закладів
професійної освіти і в нас вона мала
назву приклади руку до цю візуал до цієї
компанії нам допомогли розробити наші
партнери
інститут прожектор і ми їм надзвичайно
вдячні тому що
працювали з молоддю де На кого ми
сьогодні орієнтуємося і намагалися
звертатися до них зрозуміло для них
мовою і через зрозумілі для них канали
комунікації Ми також внесли зміни до
типових правил прийому і передбачили на
сьогодні можливість подання документів
через електронний кабінет це начебто як
і не зовсім профорієнтуватися але це
власне ті можливості які ми додатково
створюємо для наших майбутніх Ми
сподіваємося здобувачів освіти для того
щоб можна було з будь-якого місця кінця
України подати документи за бажаною
спеціальністю У обраний заклад освіти і
скоро ми вже перейдемо до тестування
цієї системи і вже наступний новий рік
ми сподіваємося буде зручно всім і
здобувачам освіти і закладам не треба
буде робити якісь додаткові відомості
таблички А все можна буде отримувати в
автоматизованому вигляді
ми реалізували продовжується це
реалізація Я думаю що багато його
користується відповідальним за
реалізацію цього проекту є інститут
модернізації змісту освіти і сьогодні ми
теж поговоримо про цей проект
всеукраїнський проект профорієнтації та
побудови кар'єри обери професію своєї
мрії він продовжує свою роботу там ціла
низка різних активностей тестування теж
про відео про професії професії
спеціальності Він охоплює всі сфери і
професійно-технічний фахової перевищує
вищої освіти Але звичайно допомагає
зробити наступні кроки І краще
орієнтуватися у світі професії за
підтримки програми юфс Skills власне
спільно з нашими вчити про польськими
колегами було розроблено посібники з
профорієнтації для молодшого шкільного
віку вони інтерактивні вони з qr-кодами
вони стосуються різних напрямків
професії і це власне знову ж таки те як
ми хочемо бути ближчими до дитини і
зрозумілою мовою давати інформацію про
дорослі і серйозні речі
а також були проведені відповідні
тренінги і навчання для вчителів школи
мене колись звинуватили Навіщо ви
фокусуєтесь профонізацію на школі я кажу
так почекаєте це ж не обов'язково що
заклад профтехосвіти куди в принципі вже
приходять люди якісь відомі вже обрали
свою професію там де потрібно проводити
профорієнтацію нам в закладах більше
треба орієнтуватися на професійне
консультування і підтримку наших
здобувачів але ми взяли ми знаємо що ми
такі трошки фанати своєї справи і любимо
ходити по школах і розказувати молоді
якою класною є профтехосвіта і що тут
треба не помилитися і зробити правильний
вибір Тому
ці навчання також для вчителів як
працювати з молоддю з цими підручниками
вони були проведені вперше Україна взяла
участь гостьову але участь в
міжнародному конкурсі International тут
нас
підтримали наші партнери компанії goe
вони сплатили я бачу колег Львівщини
участь трьох наших овочів освіти трьох
хлопців які поїхали спільно з майстром і
побачили як це відбувається і
найголовніше мабуть реакція це те в
якому захваті вони повернулися але
на питання чи важко було Вони сказали
так дуже важко надзвичайно складний
конкурс і
Ми продовжуємо рух Walt Skills Ми теж
плануємо на наступний рік якщо все буде
добре брати участь у євро-стіллс теж
поки що гостюву на жаль але ми хочемо
максимально наближатися до європейських
і світових стандартів у професіях А для
цього треба вчитися у кращих це це 100%.
тому
початок вже є Тепер продовжуємо
розвиватися але рух Walt Skills
International - це в кожній країні це
такий знаєте потужний
потужний потяг який всіх цей колдерів
всі хто пов'язаний з профорієнтацією він
залучає і всі разом якраз максимально
поширюють інформацію про можливості
професійній освіті і про можливість
взагалі кар'єрного розвитку подальшому в
нас на сьогодні вже функціонує 225
центрів кар'єри в закладах
професійно-технічної освіти
спілкуючись з вами Шановні колеги
освітяни я знаю проблеми знаю що немає
штатних розписах відповідних одиниць
знаємо що для того щоб робити цю роботу
треба мати певні навички треба теж
навчатися це цьому не вчать на сьогодні
на жаль в університетах і тут нас
підтримують інші партнери які теж
пропонують різні курси
допомагають нам з іншими проектами
неурядовими організаціями для розбудови
цієї спроможності центрів кар'єри і ми
сподіваємося що наступні декілька років
ми так маємо матимемо такий бум і не
просто а в кожному закладі професійної
освіти буде центр кар'єри ми розробили
за програмою за підтримки програми you
Force власне тут Роман і Дмитро наші
колеги концепцію діяльності і розвитку
центрів кар'єри в закладах і в місті
регіонів вони всі закладів вже проведені
відповідні тренінги причому ці тренінги
проводяться в такій синергії коли
навчаються як учні
викладачі
адміністратори Тобто це таке комплексний
підхід який якраз показує як має ця
система професійної орієнтації
кар'єрного консультування працювати в
закладі
спільно з громадською організацією
корпоративної соціальної
відповідальності організована онлайн
захід дівчата в стартапах Так ми не
забуваємо про гендер ми розуміємо що
залучати дівчат до технологічного
складних професій треба і це дуже
важливо Я наприклад тільки повернулась з
компанії Siemens була там на певній
екскурсії коли заходиш в групу а в групі
шість дівчат і двоє хлопців
і вони програмісти Я кажу А як у вас так
сталося вони кажуть Ну то раніше були
стереотипи А зараз стереотипи подолані
то нам треба теж долати ці стереотипи
е-е В нас всі українці є дуже розумними
і тому треба обирати фах за покликанням
і презентовано інструментарій для
центрів кар'єри кар'єри який був
розроблений за підтримки також проекту
юсеїд економічна підтримка України там є
все що потрібно для центру кар'єри можна
вже готові бланки шаблони документів
можна брати і використовувати тому ми
намагаємося у співпраці з нашими
партнерами колегами максимально
спростити полегшити і підтримати
в напрямку профорієнтації що стосується
цифр Ну я теж їх люблю В нас за цей рік
було проведено
1370 профорієнтаційних заходів на базі
закладів і залучено 49 тисяч учнів Я
розумію що може мене всіх дорахувалися
але загалом розуміємо яку частину
охопили І що мабуть найбільше захоплює
те що незважаючи на ні на що на
відключення світла вибухи ці заходи
відбуваються ці онлайн-екскурсії я сама
Просто інколи долучаюся бо онлайн не
відкритих дверей
Ну вже багато креативу нашій директори і
ваші колективи просто просто це щось є
неймовірне і ми вам дуже вдячні за це я
думаю що Наші учні було чи теж це
оцінюють
які канали ми використовуємо як я вже
говорила це змій Звичайно це сайти
сторінки про те як у фейсбуці Інстаграмі
зараз надзвичайно велика кількість Я
просто знаю я так стежу Це запис роликів
у Тік тоці власне такий тренд знову ж
таки орієнтуємося на тих хто нас
дивиться і тим хто нам цікавий були
прекрасні в рамках компанії білборди
постери і наші ролики теж транслювалися
І е-е я точно знаю що ми ну тут багато
теж вклали на те щоб навчити як
працювати з медіа Якщо говорити про
інформаційну кампанію Я думаю що всі
бачили ролики вони так про молодих людей
і і людей які трошки досвідченіші там
про те як вони робили свій вибір що їм
допомогло визначитися в житті
ми не будемо зараз його переглядати
трошки про саму кампанію все працює
завдяки нам є відповідний сайт там є
цікавинки На нього можна зайти
спробувати навіть собі стількири
замовити 8 відео історій та одне
промовідео і про Цифри знову ж таки
понад 1 млн переклад переглядів і
головне відео це 982 тисячі ну зрозуміло
що це за підтримки рекламної але все ж
таки це дуже відчутно і трошечки візуала
то той інформаційної компанії переклади
руку до ви бачите яка вона така яскрава
активна ми повернулись до концепції рук
там Бо ми розуміємо що це обов'язково
хтось щось має бути робити руками але
наша рука така вона допитлива вона
цікавиться всім що навколо вона все хоче
спробувати і ми надзвичайно раді що наші
колеги власне скористалися цією
можливістю і в своїх навіть
інформаційних матеріалах ви почали
використовувати цю айдентику
якщо говорити ще про досягнення воно не
трошки профорієнтацію але воно дуже
допомагає ми спільно з програмою Forest
hels також запустили онлайн-курс де
вчаться 200 педагогів скоро буде
випускний який називається видно курс
чому видно курс це про те щоб нас
побачили щоби бути побаченими і на
виднокурсії вчаться всі ті хто забажав і
хто хоче промотувати заклади професійної
освіти і власне свою сферу я знаю що там
дуже інтеракти навчання І власне там
вчать таких цікавих інструментів як
зробити профорієнтацію ефективнішою
цікавішою в тому числі як працювати з
медіа що таке медіаплани через які
канали на які цільові групи працювати як
формувати ключові повідомлення Це дуже
важливо тому що
ми в обмежених ресурсах зараз і ми
розуміємо що їх завтра більше не стане
Можливо зменшиться Тому нам треба
працювати з вищою ефективністю Та тут
треба говорити не про кількість А про
якість тому працюємо над якістю Ну і про
виклики бо тема моїй доповіді бо
доповіді була власне місто слово це
виклики почну з кінця це Імідж Так це
чому ми запустили цей видно курс ми
працюємо над зміною іміджу протехів це
необхідність наскрізної інтеграції
профорієнтації в шкільній програмі і
підручники вже є посібники розроблені
для молодшого шкільного віку зараз
програ інтегровані вже комплексно заходи
по профорієнтації для базової школи і в
нас наступний крок який ще не
пропрацьований це Старша школа профільна
школа це відсутність ресурсів для
профорієнтаційних заходів ми всі
розуміємо щоби організувати екскурсію
когось кудись відвезти завести провести
майстер-клас треба мати
відповідні матеріали навіть для того щоб
майстер-клас не знаю з фарбування стін
провести це обмеженість можливість щодо
проведення заходів тривоги
небезпека певний страх вони звичайно
заважають але ми тут винахідливі і
будемо продовжувати на цьому Ну і це те
що я казала потреба у навчанні
консультантів з профорієнтації Дякую
партнерам які вже висловилися і ми
сподіваємося що на наступний рік цих
можливостей для навчання буде більше
власне Сьогодні одна з них ми сьогодні
транслюємося онлайн тому кожен сьогодні
завтра або тоді коли йому зручно може
повернутися і переглянути і я сподіваюсь
дійсно почерпнути щось корисне Дякую
колеги я сподіваюсь не перебрала з часом
романи дякую вам дуже пані Ірина
і Дякуємо за те що поділилися вже
здобутками і про виклики дійсно ми
бачимо ми своїх кожен знаємо ми їх
впевнено долаємо І певен що всі
подолаємо так і маємо нові плани звісно
будуть і нові виклики але будуть і нові
здобутки і нові результати тож Дякуємо
дуже ми колеги продовжуємо працювати в
рамках нашої конференції про професійно
орієнтацію і ми звісно з вами нація
Незламна Так але певні технічні моменти
є тому ми трошки змінимо порядок
спікерів До речі з її спікерів і
слухачів з нами в онлайні вже більше 60
тож разом нас дійсно вже більше ста
учасників Я вдячний тим хто
підключається бачу нас чудова географія
і наживо і в онлайні від Львівщини до
Харківщини Дніпропетровщини І далі так
вся Україна сьогодні разом з нами на
цьому заході і наступна наша тема ми
будемо з вами зараз говорити власне про
ще одну можливість саме можливість Так
це про проект обери професію своєї мрії
Які знову ж таки є з українським
реалізується
міністерством освіти та науки України
проект присвячений професійній
орієнтації і побудови кар'єри і
презентуватиме його для нас пані Оксана
воронкина координаторка освітніх програм
асоціації інноваційної та цифрової
освіти пані Оксана бачимо вас чудово
Добрий день
Добрий день усіх вітаю всіх присутніх на
цій конференції До речі я якраз
продовжую доповідь пані Ірини і
познайомлю вас саме з інструментами і
трошки відповім на ці виклики Да що вже
є розроблене щоб ці виклики ми
подолали і
задля цього я уникнути демонстрацію
екрану і представлю вам
всеукраїнський проєкт всеукраїнський
всеукраїнську платформу з
профорієнтацією та побудови кар'єру яка
називається обери професію своєї мрії
цей проєкт розробляла Наша команда
спільна з
товариствами чарль ю інститутом
модернізації змісту освіти для
Міністерства освіти і науки всі ці
ресурси які я зараз представлю всі ці
інструменти вони прийшли повністю
перевірку дуже вивчався досвід
познайомлюсь з тестом профорієнтацією
аналогів якому в принципі навіть у світі
немає ми розробляли
спільно з нашими фахівцями відомими
профорієнтологами психологами ця
платформа
розрахована в першу чергу на
шкільну молодь да тобто на дітей від 12
до 25 років цей тест євалідним і
приступимо да я покажу що це за
платформи
задля того щоб користуватися
послугами на цій платформі необхідно
зареєструватися ми зараз знаходимось в
моєму екаунті так само
ми зараз все ще бачимо презентацію
можливо вам треба зупинити трансляцію
ви бачите коли я
от зараз національне курсує дослідження
бачимо Все ми зараз на сайті я прямо
буду показувати
саме сайт як користуватися сайтом ще
послуги які розташовані на сайті
переходимо
я
Які ресурси Да і почну спочатку тобто
основне що є на цьому сайті це
тестування з профорієнтацією
це тестування яке я вже сказала
розраховувала на дітей від 12 років в
цьому тестуванні складений
відомі технології два тести одночасно це
методика Джона холланда і
методика
гарднера
визначення
типів інтелектів і типу в особистості
щоб почати просто необхідно Нажати
кнопку розпочати
сам тиск займає приблизно 30 хвилин
так само нажимаємо Да і дитина
щоб відповіти необхідно розташовувати
тобто є
питання і відповідно до цього питання
необхідно розташовувати В правій колонці
перетягувати відповіді саме в
пріоритетними для вас порядку
неправильних відповідей самому цьому
тесті немає да тобто
система прилаштована таким чином
що людина відповідає Саме так як
відповідно для неї
Я зараз покажу як перетягнути і перейти
дальше
в кожному блоці є певне певні кількість
питань наприклад в цьому блоці
8 питань на визначення типів інтелектів
А на визначення типів особистості питань
якщо система бачать да Що у вас
переважає наприклад той чи інший тип не
переважає да тобто ще вона не може
віднайти який тип особистості або
інтелекту
переважають саме у вас то додаються
додаткові питання і потім коли ми
переходимо нажимаємо далі зараз покажу
результат проходитиму повністю не будемо
результат зберігається у вашому профілі
ось результати тестування дитина
бачить який типи інтелекту у неї
провалює типу особистості зараз система
[музика]
вже більш осучаснена і тепер ще
випадають запропоновані професії для
дитини які відповідають тому чи іншому
типу інтелекту або типу особистості
прочитати про ці типи так само може
людина да передивитися відео
що далі які інструменти
є далі для тих хто працює з
профорієнтацією це там більшості наш
шкільні психологи та соціальні педагоги
після того як дитина пройшла тестування
і визначилась певні професії
у нас є
дізнайся про професію своєї мрії
відповідно до тих професій дитина вже
бачить які професії наприклад цікаві
на сайті представлено більше 100
професій постійної де розробка цих
професій додаються на сайт професії
абсолютно різні Ми намагалися зробити це
не просто відео
курси це курс у міжнародному форматі з
корм інтерактивних формат кожний урок
складається кожний курс складається з
трьох уроків Перший урок - це визначення
саме що це за професія другий урок який
необхідно мати саме навички Soft skill і
Hard скіли задля цієї професії тобто
навіть якщо якихось скелів дасох скілів
відповідно до тієї чи іншої професії у
дитини не вистачає то звичайно Вона може
розвинути ці скіли і третє
сучасні вже такі
налаштування де можна працювати до по
тій чи іншій професії всі ці курси ми
розробляли спільно з навчальними
закладами де навчаються цим професіям
та спільно з
організаціями
будь-якими там фірмами Да Де можна
працювати за тією чи іншою професією
тобто
дуже-дуже багато фахівців брали участь
саме в цьому зараз я покажу що таке
скоронформат
там наприклад фахівець скасував
корпоративної соціальної
відповідальності Ми відкриємо і те що я
говорила так кожний курс так само
необхідно зареєструватися
Зараз швидко зайду
так щоб вони витрачати час повернемось
тому що так само в мене не дуже
стабільний Інтернет щоб розпочати
займатися необхідно так само
зареєструватися і можна передивлятися
той чи інший курс
ось приблизно щоб ви бачили що таке
скоронформат інтерактивний формат
нажимаючи далі в кожному курсі є певний
провідник тестування вкладених саме курс
і після проходження
дитина отримує сертифікат про
проходження
так само на сайті не тільки є
інформація для дітей щоб
зараз Зупиню
перепрошую за технічні моменти
перейду на платформу
щоб швидше
[музика]
на нашому сайті є дуже-дуже багато
інформації не лише для дітей а так само
і для батьків
потім покажу ще інструменти для освітян
будь ласка дуже багато уроків з
профорієнтації так
[музика]
так ось ці відео лекції будуть цікаві
абсолютно всім в тому числі є спеціальні
курси і для батьків і для освітяни і для
дітей як правильно складати резюме Як
правильно підготувати відеорезюме тобто
дуже-дуже багато інформації абсолютно
нової сучасної
розробленої в таких
інтерактивному такому форматі
задля того щоб діти взагалі Діти
освітяни і батьки розуміли що таке
взагалі профорієнтація
ще до освітян я хочу представити вашій
увазі
курс підвищення кваліфікації школа
кар'єрного консультанта ми його
розробляли спільно з агрохолдінгом
астарта Цей курс є валідний видається по
закінченню цього курсу сертифікат щоб
отримати необхідно пройти саме курс який
складається з 10 модулів прислухати
вебінар від відомої кар'єри не
консультанки яка саме спеціалізується на
роботі з підлітками дітьми це Ганна
різнищенка і ви можете отримати
сертифікат
як кар'єрного консультанта і проводити
консультації з дітьми
ось модулю опис програми
ось те що говорила складається
з 10 осіб цей модуль
принцип той самий Я вже не буду
показувати да тобто сам скоро-формат
тобто будь ласка той інструмент
співпраці
і
для підготовки кар'єрних консультантів у
наших закладах освіти ще хочу вам
такий
невеличкий інсайт
Наша команда і спільна звичайно з
міністерством освіти і науки
з Нового року
в Рівненській області буде створені
цифрові центри для дітей і в рамках
цього проєкту цей проект буде
відбуватися у Рівненській області за
підтримки донорських організацій
зараз якраз ведуться перемовини там
останнє Скажімо так перемовини щодо
створення цих центрів і в рамках цих
центрів буде можливість
надання профорієнтаційних послуг
індивідуальних кар'єрними консультантами
для школярів
Рівненської області про це звичайно буде
інформація і на сайті Міністерства
освіти і науки
звичайно в Рівненській
облдержадміністрації про це будуть знати
і ми повідомимо звичайно про це тому
процес рухається повністю змінюється
система профорієнтації
і будь ласка є вже інструменти абсолютно
безкоштовні інструменти якими можна
користуватися тут і зараз
вже у своїй роботі і ми дуже-дуже будемо
в Раді Якщо ви будете це робити якщо є
якісь питання У мене в принципі все
презентацію я би задоволенням відповіла
на питання Так дякую вам дуже пані
Оксана дійсно іноді ми маємо
необхідність працювати digitalo так і
загалом якість на репрезентація на
цифрових платформах і міфікація яка
запроваджується якому побачили також в
тому числі є дуже корисною для того щоб
максимально якісно було прийнято нашими
учнями здобувачами студентами тому
дійсно Дякую вам за корисний проект і
колеги якщо маєте запитання то маємо час
Хто має запитання можете підняти рукою
от запитання
А я думала тебе з вами Ліна вона зможе
відповісти на орфомента всі якщо маєте
запитання до Оксани
а тоді пані Оксана Ми дуже дякуємо вам
без я запитання Ага прошу
мікрофончик вимкнути а вже включили пані
Оксана Доброго дня колеги Вітаю всіх
Донеччина представляємо про втиха світу
методична служба Донеччини Скажіть будь
ласка чи є таке планування
реклами анонсу цієї платформи для того
щоб ці можливості оце анкетування
тестування дійшли до учнів закладів
загальної середньої освіти дякую
звичайно була реклама ця платформа
створена була
ще в минулого року і після створення вся
інформація Щодо цієї платформи є на
сайті Міністерства освіти і науки були
певні презентації у нас наша команда
створює зараз в Україні в українській
освітній хаби освітні також спільно з
міністерством освіти і науки і
модернізації змісту освіти де ми
звичайно це не єдина та програма яку має
в арсеналі Міністерства освіти і науки
просто зараз наждахівці стосується
профорієнтації це одна з платформ
безкоштовних
інструментів які можна використовувати
ця платформу будь ласка будь-хто може
користуватися і вся інформація є на
сайті Міністерства освіти і науки
Дякую Дуже за відповідь і дякую ще раз
за те що долучилися за те що розказали
нашим учасникам про цю платформи
презентували її в роботі тож Дякую вам
бажаю спокійно плідного дня і почуємося
знову Дякую Оксана
а ми з вами продовжуємо працювати колеги
І власне продовжуємо говорити про
професійну орієнтацію зокрема такою якою
вона є зараз які аспекти варто врахувати
в сучасних умовах так для цього я прошу
включити пані алевтину садоченко
експертко-професійної орієнтації проекту
і у фоскілс можемо будь ласка підключити
Вітаю вас Мене звуть алехтина сидоченко
Я експертка з професійної орієнтації
програми і ю фоскілз І сьогодні я радий
вітати рада вітати всіх учасників форуму
щодо нових практик і нових підходів до
професійної орієнтації І я рада буду
поділитися тим що ми напрацювали з
колегами протягом двох років одразу
скажу що я
долучалася онлайн і якщо ви почуєте
якісь гучний звук не лякайтеся це може
спрацювати генератор який на вулиці Отже
я попередила я підключаю презентацію і
почнемо
професійна орієнтація в закладах освіти
в сучасних умовах коли ми будемо
говорити про сучасні умови Я одразу
попереджу що це сучасні умови
сучасні умови війни тому
будемо актуальні і будемо відповідати
вимогам часу Отже перед тим як перейти
саме до тих практик які ми напрацювали я
хочу розказати про всеукраїнський
освітній експеримент професійної
орієнтація нуш які проводить наша
програма
UFO Skills кращі практики для сучасної
України яка працює саме для того щоб
підтримувати реформу
професійно-технічної освіти в Україні і
в межах цієї програми в 21-му році ми
почали освітній експеримент партії на
орієнтація нуш питає якого розробити та
перевірити ефективність впровадження
моделі професійної орієнтація нуш в
закладах освіти в межах цього
експерименту передбачено чотири основних
завдання це розроблення
навчально-методичного забезпечення
освітнього процесу розроблення програми
професійних тренінгів для педагогічних
працівників і кар'єрних радників
розроблення профорієнтаційного курсу за
вибором 8-12 класів і повідомлення
пропозицій до нормативно-правових актів
одразу хочу сказати що ми внесли свої
пропозиції до державного стандарту
базової школи і ці пропозиції частково
були враховані також Зараз ми працюємо
над розробленням державного стандарту
для профспільної школи і наших фахівці
нашого проекту є учасниками групи яка
саме працює над розробленням цього
стандарту Тому
професійна орієнтація там буде
представлена ширше ніж вона була до
цього
експеримент в експеримент залучено 44
школи з 8 областей і ми почали працювати
ще до війни
був певний етап коли ми
переналаштувалися на нову ситуацію але
зараз Ми продовжуємо свою роботу і я
хотіла поділитися
експериментів можна використовувати на
виховних годинах для того щоб проводити
тижні дні професії професійні свята
різні позакласні заходи також це є
велика допомога для вчителів в яких є
абіція створювати свої власні уроки
давайте подивимося що всередині
Як ви бачите це не інформації Я про те
які є професії Ми розказуємо які є
професії і показуємо їх от До речі ви
його розумієте можете бачити
зварювальника про якого Ми розказуємо у
книжці про мандрівні професії в нас є
багато медіафайлів посилань на відео на
мультфільми
навчальні тобто дуже багато того що
залучає дітей і мотивує їх пізнавати
світ професій інтерактивно
нас дуже багато завдань Які діти можуть
робити на уроках або робити навіть вдома
самі і ми даємо всі візуальні інструкції
як як щось робити От наприклад ви бачите
такий лабіринт
це із книжки про інженерні професії
Необов'язково знаєте коли ми кажемо про
інженерні професії то в нас таке Що це
має бути якась тема лабораторія там я не
знаю купа всього
чого от зараз в наших умовах сьогодні
дуже важко знайти і ми не можемо
розраховувати що це в нас буде в кожній
школі і ми можемо з цим працювати але
інженерна Професія - це і такий тем який
можна робити з підручних матеріалів
Давайте ми наприклад розробимо
модель телескопа
або ми зробимо Лабіринт або ми зробимо
якусь там домівку для для тварин Це все
дає можливість занурюватися в світ
професій буквально
зараз не без усілякої підготовки і ці
наші посібники помагають дуже
допомагають у цьому
ось досвід вчительки гапонюк Людмила
Миколаївна вона робила Що це До війни в
січні 22-го року Вона із рожищева
четвертий клас 26 учнів
вчителька взяла для роботи посібник
Працюємо з природою і опрацьовуючи
природничі теми Вона запропонувала учням
також зануритися в професію ландшафтного
дизайнера або озеленювача і розробити
макет квітника
І що вияснилося що роблять чи цю роботу
щодо розроблення макету квітника ми
можемо отримати результати
чотири результати з однієї цієї дії
по-перше ми опрацьовуємо природничі теми
в межах інтегрованого курсу Я досліджую
світ тому що Ідея цього проекту була в
тому що ти маєш розробити квітник який
квітне від зими до весни тобто треба
підібрати квіти щодо періоду їхнього
цвітіння і таким чином щоб в нас
квітничок був гарнесенький протягом
якомога дошого часу і це робота в межах
оцього курсу Я досліджую світ також це є
занурення в професії бо ми на практиці
розуміємо В чому є робота І в чому
займаються представники професій тобто
ландшафтний дизайнер або зелені очі він
не просто десь там садить квіти він
розробляє він він міркує які квіти
посадити він розробляє макет свого
свого квітника Тобто це певна робота а
не просто посадити квіти Також ми
проводимо діагностика особистості без
опитувальників Зверніть увагу на те як
підійшли до виконання цього завдання
Діти хлопчик ліворуч ви бачите він
намалював схему вона дуже така
геометрична там геометричні фігури це в
нього таке блоки це сектори його його
квітничка і
в нього також на цьому папірці було був
перелік квітів він який іде і в якому
своєму будинку
Мені важко говорити
до цього завдання трошечки по-іншому і
педагогами ми кажемо що професійна
орієнтація це комплексна діяльність - це
система і Отже цей підручник цей
посібник дасть можливість
розгортати цю систему
використовують реальність сценарії для
занять їх дуже багато якщо я не
помиляюсь так більше 50 Тобто це майже
на весь рік Ви маєте роботу і ви маєте
основу для того щоб розвивати професійну
орієнтацію в закладі освіти поділитися
універсальним методом ліхтари маркер це
наша ноу-хау в межах нашого експерименту
Ми з вчителями розробили такі методи які
дозволяє
будь-кому хто
впроваджує професійну орієнтацію навіть
не без усілякої додаткової підготовки
сам її впроваджувати що цей метод
передбачає це перше висвітлення або
підсвітлення певної теми привернення
уваги до певної галузі професії видів
діяльності результатів тієї діяльності
знань вмінь якості та характеристики які
мають бути у представників певної
професії далі після того як ми
підсвітили ми промарковуємо тобто
активуємо
зацікавленість інтерес учнів щодо цього
ставимо запитання обговорюємо
рефлексуємо щодо зацікавленості у
професії та різних видах діяльності які
якості учень або учениця мають розвинути
якщо вони хочуть розвиватися в цій
професії які їхні потенціали опанування
професії тощо Ну і вправи і завдання
до речі ті посібники які ми розробляли
для тих 4 класів учасники нашого
експерименту кажуть що вони навіть в
сьомому класі їх використовують
і
в цьому класі до речі теж робила от ці
роботи щодо розроблення свого квітника
тому творчий підхід і використання
якихось речей які раніше ми навіть і не
думали про це бо знаєте професійна
орієнтація о треба пройти тренінг так
тренінг можна пройти але вже зараз можна
щось робити для того щоб впроваджувати
професійну орієнтацію поки ти не прийшов
якусь якийсь тренінг або не потрапили на
такий от форум як вона зараз
відбувається
Також я хочу вас запросити на нашу
сторінку у Фейсбуці вона називається
професійна орієнтація в новій
українській школі Остапа вона виглядає
будь ласка Підписуйтесь тому що на цій
сторінці ми постійно викладаємо нові
матеріали які ми готуємо і в принципі
всілякі новинки
це в принципі те що я хотіла сказати і
вже завершуючи свою презентацію Я хочу
поділитися
спостереженням учасниці нашого
експерименту яка сказала що ви знаєте
коли я говорю з учнями про те що треба
саморозвиватися про те що треба
спробувати різні професії що треба
думати що треба
постійно рефлексувати і задавати ставити
собі питання
чи подобається Чи це мені чи хочу я в
цьому розвиватися А в чому я був або
була хорошою А що я трошечки не доробила
вона каже що я і сама для себе сприймаю
цю культуру вона входить в мене я і сама
стаю більш структурованою щодо того що я
роблю Я кожного вечора себе запитую а як
взагалі пройшов Мій день і в мене
кожного вечора є така п'ятихвилинка
розмови
самою з собою і вона каже що навчаючи
учнів таким от інтерактивним чином я і
сама стаю сильнішою я і сама розвиваюся
і я хочу нам всім побажати самого такого
підходу коли ми результат отримуємо
такий багатовекторний результат тобто
навчаючи учні учнів і проводячи
професійно-орієнтацію ми і самі трошечки
щось для це для себе з цього навчання
отримуємо
це дуже важливо не тільки для учнів а
для нас тому що країна яку відбудовуємо
і будемо далі відбудовувати після
перемоги вона буде іншою вона вже не
буде такою як була і саме тому і
професійна орієнтація і ми і Наші учні
ми маємо бути іншими маємо набути зовсім
інших знань вмінь навичок і розуміння
світу як такого для того щоб бути
здатними побудовувати нову країну
абсолютно нову країну Я дуже сподіваюся
що в нас скоро буде ця можливість роботи
це вже в мирний час і що перемога буде
скоро і я дуже нам всім Цього бажаю
до побачення дякую вам
дитина і дійсно перемога обов'язково
буде скоро наша перемога І до речі про
те як же все-таки працювати в контексті
профорієнтації не лише з учнями тими
кого ми вже навчаємо а й з середньою
молодшою не відшкодою Коли ще можливо
діти Несвідомо думають про роботу Так і
це нормально явище про те як з ними
правильно коректно працювати які знову ж
таки інструменти застосовувати про це ми
поговоримо в рамках панельної дискусії
яка теж сьогодні запланована але це
невеличкий інтро А зараз ще одна приємна
активність Так це невеличка перерва для
учасників які з нами в
віддаленому форматі ми повернемося до
роботи об 11,25 тобто за 10 хвилин тож
можна не відключатися Ми зараз робимо
тут наживо невеличку паузу маємо 10
хвилин перерви я учасників запрошую
праворуч від мене зона для кавабрейку
тож 10 хвилин перепочити підзарядити
такі власні внутрішні батарейки ми з
вами маємо дякую
Естонії та Польщі за сприяння
міжнародних організацій таких як jz та
інших за підтримки асоціації і федерації
роботодавців України за підтримки
Міністерства освіти науки України тож
нас є багато заходів учасниками яких ви
були учасниками яких ви є прямо зараз з
учасниками яких Ви ще будете протягом
найближчих двох місяців ще 23-го року
Сподіваємось що переможно для України
року Так віримо в ЗСУ ми будемо
продовжувати працювати тож коли колеги
колеги
Да ви правильно пропонуєте і ми власне
будемо продовжувати нашу секцію і
наступні наші практичні вже блохи вони
присвячені знову ж таки нашим аспектам
роботи нашим кращим практикам такі як і
вже впроваджуються професійні орієнтації
тому що тема для нас насправді не нова і
кожен навіть коли ще не було
виокремленого центру кар'єри закладу
професійно-технічної освіти в когось
вони дійсно вже діють І от краще
практики краще представники такі
кар'єрів вже поділяться своїми
результатами в кого вони лише
створюються але суть у тому що завжди ми
навіть в рамках звичайних За звичайного
освітнього процесу займалися
професійно-орієнтацією з роботою з
нашими учнями так їх і кар'єрним
консультуванням в тому числі тож це все
вже було вже має певні напрацювання а те
як це класно варто правильно розвивати в
рамках власне роботи Центру кар'єри і то
як це реально працює в закладах
професійної освіти України з нами
зібралися одразу 4 представники які
мають чим поділитися мають що розказати
про свої досвіди впровадження І власне
до цього ви переходимо у нас буде такий
Я б сказав Бліц тому що дуже такі
лаконічні але влучні презентації на нас
чекають і першою до слова Я хотів би
запросити пані Катерину Шевченку
керівника центру кар'єри вищого
професійного училища №7 міста Кременчука
Полтавської області прошу вас
Доброго дня шановні колеги для мене є
велика честь
відзвітувати ще про роботу нашого
колективу вони звати Катерина Шевченко
як керівник центру вищого професійного
училища номер сім міста Кременчука
Полтавської області це потужний
навчальний заклад який має 5 напрямків
підготовки такі як машинобудування
будівельні
інформаційно-комунікаційні принципи
напрямок і охоплює дуже багато
активностей і дійсно є чим з вами
поділитися думаю що профорієнтацію
доволі таки поширений процес який працює
в кожному навчальному закладі і тому
напрямки центру кар'єри саме по
профорієнтації очолює наш відділ Ми
допомагаємо сучасної молоді Ми
допомагаємо нашим уже випускникам
майбутньому випускникам зорієнтуватися в
світі професії і в подальшому своєму
кар'єрному шляху тому і виступаємо
надійними партнерами у
сфері роботи роботодавців і формування
якісного кадрового резерву для
досягнення в принципі позитивних таких
кроків у профорієнтації ми виділили щоби
наступні траєкторії по профорієнтації І
запрошую вас подивитися на них щодо
інформаційної і діагностичної функції і
профорієнтацією ми використовуємо
перевірені дійсно вже платформи які
сьогодні були озвучені і дійсно ці
платформи вони якісні вони зручні вони з
україномовними контентом це такі
платформи Міністерство освіти центру
зайнятості і платформи які додають
можливості для тестування І дійсно
активностей дітей учнівської молоді для
продовження свого кар'єрного шляху щодо
названих сьогодні житлової платформи
свій професії яка тільки запускається
дуже цікаво висвітлення всі навчальні
заклади дуже важливо щоб можна було
дитині вибрати саме ту професію яка буде
активна для неї і буде зручно для
транспортної розв'язки і навчання саме
її регіоні компанії комунікації які вже
сьогодні не будуть дублювати тому що ці
всі компанії які були озвучені вони
дійсно дієві вони актуальні для молоді
вони цікаві вони поширені і в принципі
не дають можливості повністю
познайомитися з нами і сказати що дійсно
професійна освіта це дуже круто Ми
співпрацюємо центр кар'єри з Державної
службою зайнятості і на його сайті є
можливість Пройти тестування анкетування
дуже багато відео стрімів і в принципі
що розшуки
інформаційний підґрунтя для ознайомлення
з професією І ще хотіла б зазначити таку
платформу як кар'єр-хаб - це платформа
розвитку кар'єри які були розроблені
конкретно
мапи професійної діяльності тобто
рекомендаційні інфографіки від самого
початку профорієнтації і довше
результатів коли дитина має освіту і
може спрямувати свою навички які і
тверді щодо формування своїх кар'єрного
шляху
найкращими
профорієнтаторами є і завжди залишаються
наші здобуваючою освітою до випускники
ми Дуже радіємо за їхні успіхи ми знаємо
і їхнім прикладом поширюємо всю
інформацію та навчальний заклад І
важливим варіантом досягнення серед
молоді в принципі краще ніж орієнтатори
Наші учні немає нікого ми Дуже радіємо
коли наші випускники проводять навчатися
вже своїх дітей Вони відзначають
динаміку і позитивний розвиток нашого
навчального закладу тому що вони
зрівнюють той такий був про коли вони
навчалися і їхня оцінка є дуже важливою
для нас
Ми популяризуємо дуже наш бренд наш
бренд є на всіх логотипах На всіх
варіантах профорієнтаційної інформації в
принципі розвитку якої інформації ми
протестували дуже багато варіантів і
оголошень і буклетів і ручок і
різноманітної друкованої продукції ну
завершили свою
оцінили всі в принципі варіанти і
залишили лише флаєра і великі постери
для ознайомлення з нашими чинним
закладом наші в принципі бренд Знають
всі як Україні так знаєте за кордоном
тому що він відомий Він популярний і на
жаль або на щастя наш проект так само
віддруковується і виварюється зварниками
у нашому коли ми робимо велику роботу за
допомогою зараз по волонтерству наші
буржуйки які виготовляють наші зварники
разом з учнями вони відправляються по
всій Україні за сприяння міжнародної
організації
фінансування наших колег і надають
можливість дійсно бачити що ми вміємо ми
знаємо як і ми можемо поширити наш
логотип і наш бренд на оновленому сайті
за сприянням їм і фоскілс є інформація
вся абсолютно яка дає можливість
ознайомитися з навчальним закладом
правилами пройому дає можливість
побачити змістовну інформацію по
професії і максимально пройти ще
додатково 3D екскурсію яка адаптована
для сучасних гаджетів і дає можливість
подивитися на всі лабораторії майстерні
в принципі ознайомитися з навчальним
закладом в вигляді 3D екскурсії яка
адаптована і сучасна для
дистанційного ознайомлення з нашим
навчальним закладом
ми активні у всіх соціальних мережах
абсолютно всіх починаючи від фейсбуку
Інстаграму Тік Тока YouTube ми активно
проводимо наші заходи ні відкритих
дверей ми проводимо такі поширені
варіанти Life відео ми знімаємо наживо
ми знімаємо стрімимо як називаємо молодь
Вони потім бачать щоби І дійсно вони
комунікують розповідають далі поширюють
інформацію ніж іншими учнями які в
майбутньому приходять наші абітурієнтами
дуже класно відслідковувати дітей які
проходили на дні відкритих дверей
ярмарки вакансії на дні кар'єри і потім
уже дійсно є нашими учнями в вересні
місяці
щодо реклами підтримуємо зв'язки
абсолютно з усіма нашими мас-меді які є
в місті Кременчуці в регіоні і наші всі
заходи транслюють залюбки наші колеги
партнери постійні які додають можливості
поширити інформацію про навчальний
заклад про діяльність цього про
волонтерську діяльність про е дуже
активні наші позиції щодо співпраці і
партнерства
ми мобільні крім ні відкритих дверей ми
проводимо традиційні в принципі їх
заплановано на рік 4-5 ні відкритих
дверей але ми постійно поширюємо
практику днів абітурієнта ми працювали у
цьому півріччі по суботам то було
визначено день коли діти приходили у
вільному форматі і зустрічали наші
колеги проводили активну екскурсію по
запиту якщо дитина орієнтується знову ж
таки на професію конкретно зварника ми
проводили максимально розширені
екскурсію для того щоб дитина уже
визначилась однозначно і залишилась з
нами в майбутньому крім одні відкритих
дверей проводимо таку екскурсію
називається Автостопом по професії ми по
усім де діти мають можливість побачити
навчальний заклад з майстерні в принципі
це серце професійної освіти там де діти
учаться твердих навичок по професії і
завершуємо екскурсію в нашому діючому
музеї військової історії дуже поширений
який наповнюється постійно на жаль
останніми уламками На жаль останніми
цими
раритетними енергетими але дуже поганими
речами і в нас їх дійсно привозять
хлопці наші випускники які дарують нам
всім музей щодо партнерства ми відкриті
легко ви відкриті ми працюємо з усіма за
що можете їх коллерами роботами
проводимо екскурсії повністю Кременчуку
Горішні плавні Тобто де ми можемо пройти
де вона запрошують ми завжди є діти
активно відгукуються на різноманітні
активності і допомагають в принципі і
собі визначитися і має бути
працевлаштуванням і допомогти в принципі
своїм колегам друзям які є найменшого
формату потім визначитися про те що
дійсно Училище - це класно оці училища
це круто і ми зможемо дати першу
професійну освіту яка в майбутньому
стане гарним підгрунтям для розвитку і
продовження навчання
далі чи є плани на майбутнє їх дуже
багато насправді раніше була проблема У
нас в місті Кременчуці і зараз не працює
жодна школа абсолютно жодна школа ми
пропрацюємо всіх дистанційному форматі
але ми наполегливий душу Стараємося
співпрацювати з усіма то за період з
вересня по листопад місяць цього року
наш відвідало вже 360 учнів випускників
Ми співпрацюємо з усіма гімназіями і
вони залюбки приводять на екскурсії ми
гарні ми максимально Стараємося про це
розповісти тому Дякую за увагу Як і якщо
є якісь питання будуть рада відповісти
Дякуємо дуже якщо є питання можна
підняти руку знову таки
і запитаємося так поки бачу що немає
Тоді Ми дякуємо дуже пані Катерина
дякуємо
теж рухаємося далі і колеги для тих хто
можливо підключився до нас уже після
перерви Нагадую що ми з вами беремо
участь гібридні такі конференції краще
практики професійного орієнтації в
закладах професійною освіти
ця конференція та інші тренінги які ми
учасниками є наші заклади
професійно-професійно-технічної освіти
реалізуються в рамках програми і опус
Hills яка підтримується Євросоюзом
зокрема країнами-членами Німеччиною
Польщею
фінляндією та естонією у міжнародному
організаціями такими як Jet та іншими
міністерством освіти і науки України так
і ми продовжимо нашу роботу продовжимо
говорити про ті практики які ми вже
маємо серед здобутків
професійної орієнтації в закладах саме
професійної освіти саме роботи з учнями
і наступною до слова наступне нашої
спікеркою буде пані Олена Полюхович
Заступник директора Департаменту і
начальник управління професійної вищої
освіти фінансово-економічної кадрової
організаційний та нової роботи пані
Олена радий вам передати слово
дякую
Шановні колеги маю час сьогодні так до
вас звернутися і насправді вкрай
хвилюється адже демонструє сьогодні
профорієнтаційну роботу не тільки одного
закладу А загалом всієї області Ну що
стало поштовхом для того щоб в
Рівненській області активізувати на
високому рівні професіїну роботу це один
такий випадок ми щороку раніше до війни
проводили
виставку-ярмарку робітничих професій і
на виставці ярмарки ярмарці робітничої
професії ми робили таку
безпрограшну лотерею для маленьких діток
де вони вигравали якісь там певні речі
зроблені нашими учнями ну це звичайно що
це профорієнтаційна така робота була Ми
так думали але поставивши запитання
одному із таких маленьких діток а це
діти 6-5 років насправді маленькі Ми
зрозуміли що вони не знають професії і в
садочку в дитячому садочку граються вони
зовсім в інші ігри
граються вони в лікарів граються вони
там ну міліціонери поліцейські - це були
вкрай такі популярна така професія де
всі були поліцейськими ще ми дійшли до
кінцевого результату це були пожежники і
от це стало поштовхом для того щоб
створити потужну піар кампанію захопивши
всі вікові категорії В нашій Рівненській
області і перше що ми зробили після того
коли вийшли з такої от уже ну з такої
профорієнтації це створили ролик з
маленькими дітками який ми
запустили в наші соціальні мережі
Звичайно що маленьких діток Коли ти
знімаєш потрібно дозвіл батьків то ми ми
використовували своїх дітей Ось вони
погодилися і вони розказували яку вони
професію хочуть здобути Якщо ви хочете
побачити цей ролик тому я пропоную вам
підписатися на наші портали портал
професійна освіта Рівненщини там є цей
ролик і на портал Тепер уже Департаменту
освіти і науки там також є цей ролик Він
досить цікавий тому що вони насправді
після того коли сказали що я хочу бути
будівельником хочу бути перукарем хочу
бути кухарем вони і досі так думають і
насправді і досі планують вступати у
заклади професійної освіти
як тут можете мені допомогти будь ласка
Ну звичайно що
профорієнтаційна робота це не тільки
піар якоїсь однієї професії чи якогось
супер обладнання в першу чергу це
створення хорошої мережі закладів
професійної освіти і це не тільки стіни
це все що є сьогодні в наших закладах
рівненських це створення
навчально-практичних центрів це
створення таких консультаційних центрів
для того щоб коли будь-яка людина
приходить у заклад професійної освіти
вона отримає впродовж цілого року
навчального календарного отримає як вона
може тут себе реалізувати і кожній
людині яка до нас приходить ми можемо
запропонувати освіту впродовж життя тому
це важливо насправді профорієнтаційна
робота не тільки має завершуватися одним
закладом Вона має захоплювати всю
область
Так я зрозуміла Ну це була наша мережа
навчально-практичні центри яку мету вони
насправді переслідують
навчально-практичні центри Сьогодні в
нас це не одна лабораторія це великі
масштабні проекти які працюють як на
кожного громадянина надають послуги і ми
звичайно що проводимо такі ми Це досі
називаємо таким словом популярним але
для всіх зрозуміли екскурсії для наших
дітей Ми охопили абсолютно всі школи всі
вікові категорії і кожна школа в кожному
регіоні знає який заклад у них станом на
сьогодні існує і якщо він сучасний чи не
сучасний Звичайно що кожен заклад вони
дають таку оцінку кожен заклад сьогодні
це не просто сучасний заклад Ми прагнемо
до цього прагнемо бути на крок попереду
часу тому створюємо такі певні моменти
які сьогодні досить популярний серед
молоді
наприклад центри дистанційного навчання
Ми всі знаємо що сьогодні посадити
дитину за книжку яка уже там якогось
70-х років Це дуже важко і створили
певні там конструктори які працюють в
центрах наших навчально-практичних
центрах центри дистанційного навчання це
те що сьогодні можна транслювати
абсолютно будь-які контент будь-які
вчитель він може писати ручкою на дошці
писати ручкою в зошиті і це буде
транслюватися всім учням Хто хоче до
цього долучитися не тільки учням
наступне Ну оце мережа наших центрів
хочу сказати що навчально-практичні
центри ми не тільки акумулюємо сьогодні
в одному місті Рівному насправді вся
мережа Яка сьогодні охоплює це 19
закладів професійної освіти це вся
область кожен заклад прагне до того аби
все-таки на мапі
навчально-практичних центрів ось це мапа
навчально-практичних центрів бути з
позначкою адже це дасть можливість знову
ж таки розповідати про ту чи іншу
професію
для того щоб не бути голослівним це наші
приклади Петро Миколайович любить казати
що навчально-практичні центри не можуть
бути музеями Вони мають працювати І
навіть період війни ми все-таки зуміли
приймати людей на навчальний процес хоча
це було вкрай нелегко тому що якщо ви
знаєте Рівненська область - це 30 км
зона від кордону Ну звичайно що
формування правильне формування
регіонального замовлення правильне
формування - це коли роботодавець
пропонує хорошу роботу пропонує хороший
соціальний пакет і пропонує заробітну
плату яка сьогодні може бути актуальною
на ринку праці а з іншого боку учень
розуміє або абітурієнт в подальшому
студенту розуміє що він може за той
період часу навчитися якісно якісно
працювати на певному обладнанні тому
обладнання сучасне - це найкращий
профорієнтаційний момент який може бути
ну
вибирається Професія - це теж зрозуміло
в нас є заклади в яких 1200 контингент
ми взагалі не падаєм нижче
середньорічного контингенту 500 тому що
Ну сьогодні 42% закладів учнів
професійної освіти хочуть потрапити наші
заклади так Ну звичайно що ось я вам
покажу один приклад ми проводимо прямий
ефір і
нашим учням це подобається наступна ось
наші центри дистанційного навчання ось
ми створили в одному із закладів такий
гурток де Запрошуємо учнів закладів вони
навчаються з робототехніці звичайно бути
операторами Дронів але в подальшому вони
приходять в наш заклад це теж хороший ну
хороша така робота
з тим центри наші це також Хороша
профорієнтаційна робота
Я Хочу зупинитися на одному моменті які
ми почали працювати над ним Що до кінця
не завершили є такі предмет в школі
предмет трудового навчання і ось предмет
трудового навчання Ми хочемо викладати в
закладах професійної освіти Ми до цього
прагнемо ми вже на завершенні Я думаю що
з наступного року в нас це все вийде і
Це просто профорієнтаційна робота на
цьому не буду зупинятися Я хочу ще про
листати це наші навчально-практичний
центр показати одну річ ми захопили ну
найкраща профорієнтаційна робота це коли
ти в прямому ефірі відкриваєш центр І
коли всі дивляться як учні працюють на
тому чи іншому обладнанні це найкраща
профорієнтаційна робота вони вже лишають
школу і хочуть Ось так також працювати
ми
майже всіх проектах які сьогодні існують
по профорієнтаційній роботі один із
проектів - це Ось які ви бачите і учні
міста Рівного вже всі брали участь у
цьому проекті і вони насправді всі
хочуть бути кухарями І от мене сусідка
моя маленька дівчинка прийшовши з такого
проекту розпові А мені що я була в школі
мистецтв Я кажу ні не в школі мистецтв
сказали що Мистецтво це їжа тому Оце
така школа мистецтв
Ну звичайно що
популярні робітничих професій це
партнерство коли на високому рівні
укладаються угоди коли про тебе знають
всі про твої професії Знають всі проте
наскільки вони актуальний і Бізнес
стоїть в черзі для того щоб взяти твого
молодого робітника на роботу Оце і є
якісна профорієнтаційна робота Звичайно
що в нас існує кар'єра.in.ua це такі
сайт він у нас також був за проектом
зроблений і сьогодні Мені досить
актуальний будь-яка людина вони ми такі
сайти популяризували в школах і будь-яка
дитина може зрозуміти взагалі назви
професій не всі Діти розуміють що таке
опоряджувальник будівельний не всі Діти
розуміють що таке Сантехнік що він
робить Вони ж уявляють Що це має бути
людина яка десь там не надто якісно
вбрана і не зрозуміло що робить але коли
ти розповідаєш Яке зараз супер технічне
обладнання це зовсім інші моменти
Ну от наші діти це ви сьогодні побачите
як вони готують всі вміють готувати піцу
і Всі розуміють станом на сьогодні
досить-таки актуальне для нас було з
найпродуктів які в тебе є що ти можеш
зробити і нагодувати ще свого сусіда
Ну оце наш ролик і наші діти які
розповідали як вони хочуть які вони
хочуть бути Подивіться будь ласка це
дуже досить так щемно насправді можливо
якість там різна але все-таки щемно Ну
звичайно що в нас є певна стратегія руху
і піар компанія для професійної освіти
була є і буде і вона не може бути
актуальною та яка була минулого року
актуальною сьогодні Та яка актуальна
сьогодні не може бути актуальною завтра
тому аби охопити весь контингент
населення аби допомогти кожній у кожному
таку кожній групі населення як
зорієнтуватися в професіях і якщо ти
розчарувався навіть в своєму житті ми
теж допоможемо і теж навчимо Тому
професійна освіта - це найактуальніша
освіта яка станом на сьогодні існує
загалом в світі я так думаю і не тільки
я так думаю сьогодні Рівненська область
над цим працює Ну от
Ну і наступне Звичайно це на кого ми
орієнтуємося
Рівне Work Hub це от бізнес-платформа
яка насправді це не порожні слова Це
дуже важливо тому що ми чуємо що
говорить бізнес бізнес чує нас і Інколи
ми не завжди погоджуємося Ми виписуємо
цілий такі правила з чим ми не
погоджуємося що для нас не є актуально і
через те Сьогодні у нас такий хороший
показник виконання регіонального
замовлення Я вважаю Військовий період це
94% і якісних показник на Деякі професії
в нас є конкурси ми додатково набирали
ще по дві групи і це професія
трактористів ну це наші що насправді ми
прагнемо І що все професійна освіта і
загалом тільки свої якісь ролики
продукувати цього мало потрібно
захоплювати все те що сьогодні пропонує
для нас держава пропонує Міністерство
тому ті ролики які сьогодні заходили Від
міністерства освіти науки ми також
пускали в ротацію і вони також спра тому
що в тих роликах були Наші майстри
виробничого навчання які в свій час
навчалися в закладах і це історія успіху
тому для учня для того для школяра
потрібно сьогодні розказувати
неспростінний а розказувати яку
траєкторію успіху він може досягнути
отримавши професійну освіту і як
монетизувати своє життя дякую Я дуже
коротко все чудово Дякую вам пані Олена
найважливо не тікайте від нас можливо
питання є в наших колег можна підняти
ручку і поставити питання якщо я тоді
дякую вам Олена дуже і продовжуємо нашу
роботу Я певен що ця секція Ну дійсно є
корисною тому що це саме ті практики ті
реальні впровадження які вже є в
закладах професійної освіти і ті які ви
теж для себе можете брати на озброєння
використовувати для себе бо ви знаєте
вже не створює ви знаєте з Реальної
практики про те що такі проекти працюють
І звісно і під час Обі час інших наших
інфоксесіях ви можете наших експерток
також запитати дізнатися деталі адже це
теж є корисний аспект нашої такої
зустрічі наживо Отже продовжуємо колеги
і знову ж таки вдячний тим хто з нами в
онлайні знаходиться час знаходиться
інтернет можливість підключитися
наступна наша спікерка в блоці кращих
практик це пані Галина писаревська
заступниця директора з
навчально-виробничої роботи
Чернівецького вищого професійного
училища радіоелектроніки радий передати
вам слово дякую добрий день дорогі
колеги я представляю Чернівецькі вищі
професійне училище радіоелектроніки це
Чернівецька область Мене звати Галина
писаревська Я є заступницею директора з
навчально-виробничої роботи я звичайно
впевнена що ту роботу яку представляю Я
ви робите всі на своїх робочих місцях що
таке профорієнтація У кожної людини є
свобода вибору вибір у нас існує щоденно
ми
дві хвилини задаємо дуже багато
різноманітних запитань
різні посерйозності не однакові за
своїми наслідками і найбільше нас
цікавить яку дітей цікавить яку професію
обрати куди піти вчитися зробити цей
крок Чи не зробити
так чи ні Одним з найважливіших кроків в
житті є вибір професії адже Займатися
тим що тобі подобається
тим що тебе цікавить і приносить радість
одна з умов відчуття життєвої
повноцінності
вдалий вибір професії одна з головних
складових умов встановлення особистості
і усвідомлення своєї значимості в
суспільстві тут головне визначитись що
дитина хоче тобто яку професію вона хоче
обрати далі проаналізувати що вона може
тобто адекватно оцінити свої власні зді
якості та можливості Ну і звичайно що
треба
проаналізувати потребу в обраній
професії на ринку праці оцінити
перспективи кар'єрного росту з цієї з
цього обраного напрямку звичайно цими
питаннями і багатьма іншими займається
центр розвитку кар'єри у нас в області в
кожному закладі професійної освіти
створено центр розвитку кар'єри є
сторінки центрів розвитку кар'єри на
сайті закладу де розміщується план
роботи Центру кар'єри на поточний рік
звіти за минулий рік а також ті Заходи
які проводяться і дієво показують
профорієнтацію в закладі освіти
ну перш ніж
запрошувати дітей на навчання
абітурієнтів на навчання треба їх
проінформувати тобто учні мають мати
максимум інформації про професії їх
зміст статус на ринку праці рівні освіти
які даються в закладі перспективи
працевлаштування Ну і можливості
продовження навчання в цих навчальних
закладах якщо є фахові підготовка
фахових молодших бакалаврах або у вищих
навчальних закладах тут дієвим заходом
щодо професійного самовизначення
школярів є розміщення інформації про
діяльність закладів освіти
різноманітні навчальні мистецькі
спортивні досягнення здобувачів освіти
на
сайті спочатку закладу освіти які є
первинним джерелом інформації а також в
соціальних мережах
що стосується презентації закладу освіти
в інтернет та соціальних мережах то на
сайті розміщена повна інформація про
кожну професію про кожну її напрямок
підготовки YouTube канал розміщено
різноманітні відеоролики майстер-класи
уроки які проводяться в закладі також
ролики які готують учні які самі їх
знімають сторінка у Facebook також
допомагає Ну і звичайно сторінка в
Instagram ми проаналізували що діти на
сьогоднішній день більше користуються
такою
соціальною мережею як Instagram ніж
Facebook тому є сторінки у Instagram
кожного професійного напрямку Це добре
тому що кожна професія представлена в
соціальній мережі майстри виробничого
навчання Ми дуже дякуємо їм що вони
активно розповсюджуються інформацією
щодо профорієнтації а також діти активно
знімають такі невеличкі історії з своїх
виробничих уроків виробничого навчання
за років теоретичного навчання з
екскурсії Які Вони відвідують і
розміщують на в соціальних мережах це
також допомагає профорієнтації Ну і
звичайно в соціальних мере розміщуються
різні дописи історії інфографіка
презентації та багато-багато іншого
кожна професія підготувала такий
відеоролики які ми стараємось
демонструвати
в також в закладі освіти рекламуємо в
соціальних мережах Дніпра в техосвіти
які проводяться також демонструємо і що
стосується роботи з самими абітурієнтами
з самими школярами обов'язково для них є
також діагностика та консультування
тобто наші педагоги
психолог соціальний педагог майстри
виробничого навчання разом з кращими
учнями і студентські самоврядування
ідуть в школу для того щоб
могли визначити
інтереси дітей їхні напрямки в яких вони
хочуть себе реалізувати і щоб вони
зробили свідомий вибір тут звичайно йому
допомагають ті тестування які є
розміщені на сайтах і центру зайнятості
і зокрема ті сайти які пропонує
Міністерство освіти і науки далі наш
спрямування нашого закладу це більше
радіотехнічне Та електротехнічне Чомусь
так здавна склалося що Ці професії
більше для хлопців ну такі стереотипи є
в Головах людей
нам в минулому році
запропонували провести декілька
майстер-класів з серії тест-драйв
професії для дівчат організаторами якого
є програма і його форс-кілс кращі
навички для сучасної України та
Міністерства освіти і науки ми його
провели і взяли собі на замітку
проводити кожного року тому що мета цих
заходів підвищити обізнаність дівчат та
жінок про професії які можна здобути в
закладах професійної освіти технічні
професії які зазвичай вважають це
хлопчачими Ну звичайно ми ще за цих два
роки всі стереотипи не подолали Ну я
надіюся що ми перший крок вже зробили
той тестдрайв який проходив в минулому
році і той який в цьому році був досить
активним дівчатка цікавилися пробували
паяти робити практичні вправи на тих
практичних стелажах які які для них
пропонували наші майстри виробничого
навчання Ну і звичайно дні відкритих
дверей для всіх і хлопців і дівчаток
робимо рекламу у соціальних мережах
Запрошуємо
учнів та школярів і демонструємо
майстер-клас з тієї чи іншої професії з
можливістю спробувати себе тому що
найкраще запам'ятовується не те що вони
почують і побачать А те що вони
практично попробують зробити це
професії електромонтер Також ми працюємо
здобувачами освітніх послуг закладу
освіти тому що незважаючи на те що вони
вже зробили свій професійний вибір вони
мають усвідомити усвідомити свій свої
кар'єрне зростання з цієї професії і
можливості де вони можуть працювати за
цією професією яку ми не здобувають
звичайно На жаль далеко не завжди є
вибір тобто
здобувач освіти
працевлаштовується за тією професією яку
він здобуває і внаслідок чого сьогодні
дуже багато української молоді працює на
не за фахом тому тут є досить багато
таких завдань які потрібно виконувати з
здобувачами говоримо про
працевлаштування розвиваємо Soft Skills
підвищуємо цифрову грамотність
розвиваємо медіаграмотність та критичне
мислення розвиваємо підприємницькі
навички також пройшли наші педагоги
більше 10 педагогів нашого закладу
пройшли курс навички для успішної
кар'єри і вже впроваджують його у
навчальному процесі для того щоб
розвивати ці навички Ну і звичайно
досить добрим таким прикладом хорошого
кар'єрного зростання є зустрічі з
успішними випускниками закладу освіти
Щороку ми проводимо і Запрошуємо
успішних випускників які дивляться на
наші майстерні які змінюються завдяки
проекту його Skills і тій модернізації
яку Зараз проводиться то вони звичайно
хочуть кажуть що хочуть йти ще раз
вчитися далі співпраця з чернівецьким
міським та обласним центром зайнятості
тому що будь-яка професія потрібно щоб
вона була зараз
затребуваною на ринку цьому році і
здобуваючи освітніх послуг із школярі ми
їх Запрошуємо в центр зайнятості
подивитися той перелік роботодавців які
потребують на сьогоднішній день
кваліфікованих робітників для здобувачів
освіти дуже цікавими є екскурсії на
підприємства це дуже важливо тому що
вони безпосередньо бачать де вони можуть
працювати які там умови які є соціальний
пакет на цьому підприємстві далі для
молодших школярів Ну я думаю ви також
проводили таким такий цікавий був
проект місто професій для молодших діток
де вони могли познайомитися з будь-якою
професією яка представлена на ринку
праці Чернівецької області і дізнатися
про ті професії про які вони до сьогодні
не знали і спробувати себе ну цей проект
Ну перспективу тому що дітки маленькі
Також ми Стараємося в закладі освіти в
ці проводити різноманітні тренінги для
педагогів ну зокрема це один з тренінг
один з тренінгів на порозі професійного
вибору де наші педагоги вчаться як
проводити профіль орієнтацію як
працювати з школярами і тут вже такі
приклад роботи
далі Я дуже вдячна і наш заклад дуже
вдячний завдяки цій модернізації яка
проводиться на сьогоднішній день в
суспільстві рівень
професійної освіти зростає і хочеться
подякувати всім європейським партнерам
Міністерство освіти і науки України
Департаменту та директорату професійної
освіти що допомагають нам удосконалювати
цю таку важливу галузь сучасний освітній
простір повинен привернути увагу молоді
до робітничих професій а також суттєво
покращити якість підготовки учнів тих що
вже але професійну освіту
тому Дякую вам за увагу Я надіюся що ви
завітаєте на наш сайт і подивитися що ті
реклами ті
відеоролики які ми пропонуємо і нашому
учням Дякую за увагу Дякую вам пані
Галина Отже колеги традиційна сеть сесія
питань відповідей тож якщо маєте
запитання до пані Галини прошу вас
підняти руку
немає поки що запитань Добренько Дякую
Ну і Нагадую що у нас ще буде і обід
інші можливості поспілкуватися
персонально тож скористайтеся ними а Ми
продовжуємо наш блок кращих практик і
наступною нашою спікеркою буде пані
Світлана Візнюк заступник директора з
навчального виробничої роботи державного
навчального закладу Чортківські вище
професійне училище пані Світлана ради
вас вітати тут і прошу вам слово
так щиро дякую колеги
маючи сьогодні
представляти свій навчальний заклад
Чортківське вище професійне училище який
розташований у Тернопільській області
одним із чинників які сприяє
усвідомленому вибору майбутньої професії
а також побудові та реалізації своєї
професійної траєкторії кожної
особистості Звичайно що є професійна
орієнтація в нашому закладі освіти
профорієнтаційна робота вона спрямована
у великій мірі з потенційними
абітурієнтами нашого закладу освіти це
зокрема з випускниками закладів
загальної середньої освіти так і
здобувачами нашого училища а також із
дорослим населенням А якщо говорити про
нашу профорієнтаційну роботу із
випускниками закладів загальної
середньої освіти вона більше мірі
спрямована на те щоб їх проінформувати
про ось ту різноманітність такого
професійного світу про актуальність
професії на сучасному ринку праці а
також відповідно про перспективне
професійного такої професійної кар'єри з
метою інформування
закладів загальної середньої освіти
відповідно наші представники педагогічні
працівники відвідують заклади так вони
спілкуються із здобувачами освіти але не
просто спілкуються адже тому що ну
говорити про те якими хороші ми можемо
Так А вони за допомогою сучасних
комп'ютерних технологій відповідно
презентують кращий досвід і з
професійної підготовки за різними
професіями на підставі відповідно такого
спілкування
відповідно створюється банк даних
випускників долучається їх до
telegram-каналу нашого навчального
закладу і протягом усього періоду
відповідно ці учні Вони мають змогу
ознайомлюватися із скажемо так із
професійною підготовкою і відповідно Іще
із просто життям нашого навчального
закладу звичайно Також ми практикуємо як
і кожен навчальний заклад проведення дня
відкритих дверей а в рамках якого наші
професійні консультанти центру кар'єри
вони проводять тренінгові курси працюють
із нашими відвідувачами для того щоб
актуалізувати саме увагу на свідомому
вибору професії і що особливо це те що
це є тренінгові курси вони проведені Іще
до того коли здобувачі освіти уже підуть
відповідно по локаціях Так чому для того
щоб їхні відповіді і їхній вибір а він
не був побудований просто на перших
емоціях ось коли відповідно у нас
завершилася Ці тренінгові курси
здобувачі наші відвідувачі вони мають
змогу пройтись по наших майстернях де
відповідно працюють
майстер-класи вони мають змогу
прийняти участь кожен відвідувач має
змогу прийняти участь у цьому
майстер-класі Так і відповідно
зануритися у світ саме тієї професії Ми
всі дуже добре пам'ятаємо зі школи коли
на День вчителя кожен зміг себе
спробувати в ролі педагога і після того
дня вчителя всі зразу захотіли би
попробувати і захотіла б здобути цю
професію ось відповідно Також ми
практикуємо розповсюдження в населених
пунктах оголошень про освітні пропозиції
нашого закладу освіти а також розміщення
реклами на білбордах а також LED
дисплеях минулого року У нас було
розміщено реклами на трьох білбордах у
місцях найбільшого такого скупчення так
населення а також у центрі у нашому
районному центрі на але дисплеї
систематично змінювалися і
демонструвалися відеоролики із саме із
професійної підготовки на нашому
навчальному нашому навча навчальному
закладі також практиці є розміщення
реклами на радіо Львівська хвиля і
великий велику долю ми відповідно
надавали рекламі у соціальних мережах
зокрема це є Facebook Instagram і тіток
більш детально все-таки на рекламі у
соціальній мережі Facebook і відповідно
натік ток як бачимо зараз Я презентую
вам наш досвід Це надзвичайно
надзвичайно зручно адже Facebook
дозволяє можливості обрати саме вікову
категорію на кого має бути спрямована
реклама місце розташування ми завжди
обираємо цілу Тернопільську область
відповідно
стать повністю вибрати усі налаштування
на кого ми хочемо спрямовувати нашу
рекламу і після завершення цієї реклами
Відповідно ми отримаємо звіт по
кількості навіть по кількості взаємодії
із тим чи іншим дописом відповідно цю
рекламу і ці
свої дописи ми можемо міняти і це досить
є добре
також цього року наша первинна
профспілка організація учнів під
керівництвом голови первинної
профспілкової організації розпочала
роботу із популяризацією робітничих
професій за допомогою соціальної мережі
tiktok ви знаєте для початку Мені це
було дуже дивно але ми вже маємо перший
результат і перших бажаючих вступити
саме наш заклад освіти тут я маю
демонстрацію останніх дописів Як ви
можете побачити є і 200 тисяч переглядів
і 500 тисяч переглядів і час взаємодії
тобто знову ж таки ми бачимо інформацію
і Навіть наші здобувачі освіти вони самі
приходять і говорять А давайте Ну своїми
ідеями давайте як ми іще поширимо
інформацію про ту чи іншу професію яку
вони здобувають Відповідно ми всі вже
знаємо що цього року ми вже
формували проект прийому так На
наступний навчальний рік відповідно Ми
вже обговорили
актуальні професії на ринку праці
відповідно Також ми вже вирішили питання
щодо створення консультаційного центру
який буде працювати в рамках роботи
приймальної комісії і почали вже
обговорювати А які ж профорієнтаційні
заходи цього року ми будемо відповідно
здійснювати
почали розбирати проходився Як ви бачите
вже якісь тест на просування у нас є і
тоді у нас виникла така ідея А чому ж
Для прикладу не використати можливості
цифрових інструментів Google не створити
опитування між робочами освіти і уже
дізнатися так би мовити з перших вуст що
саме впливало На їхній вибір
ми обмежилися буквально декілька
запитанями як бачимо це перше
обрав професію тому що про училищі
дізнався з і поступив в ДНЗ Чортківський
ВПУ тому що
Як бачите брали професію тому що вона
подобається саме здобувачу
74,5%. із всіх респондентів які прийняли
в цьому участь зверніть увагу і будь
ласка собі запам'ятайте що 23 здобувачі
освіти вони нам надали відповідь про те
що
обрав професію тому що це був єдиний
можливий варіант обставинах що склалися
так і це також буває і ми до цього
повернемося трішки згодом
45,7% про наш заклад освіти дізналися
від товаришів і 34,2% від батьків не
можуть нарадувати Та ситуація що
44% відповідно поступили в Наше училище
тому що це було їхня самостійним таким і
свідомим вибором 60 осіб це є 24,7%
серед тих респондентів тому що
опитування ще не закінчилося що заклад
освіти територіально розташований
близько
15,2% тому що його рекомендували хрящі 5
і 3% закладу освіти обрали батьки і
увага знову ж таки ми тут бачимо цифру
26 учнів 26 добувачів які обрали заклад
освіти тому що це був єдиним можливий
варіант Ну ми підозрили про те що
найкращою нашою професійної орієнтація
то звичайно відгуки товаришів і батьків
так і тут нічого немає дивного ми Для
прикладу коли самі обираємо наприклад
якісь медичний заклад так ми спочатку
дивимося відгуки о соціальних мережах Ми
спочатку спілкуємося зі своїми
товаришами і тільки після того робимо
якісь вибір Так і профорієнтація ми
розуміємо що це є прилонгований такий
процес ми працювали над репутацією свого
навчального закладу досить довго адже
вона здатнам утримується у свідомості
людей досить довгий період і для того
щоб визначити слабкі сторони нашого
закладу освіти
за підсумками яких наш здобувач скажу до
свого колеги Так ти не поступай туди так
хто як навчальний заклад тому що там і
там Відповідно ми до свого опитування
додали ще декілька запитань зокрема для
дітей Ми додали питання Найбільше мені
тут до вподоби дальше ми додали завдання
найменше мені найбільше мені тут не
подобається і третя відповідно це є
Можливо у вас є порада для нас
реалізація яких дозволить нам
досконалюватися та збільшити кількість
здобувачів освіти
відповіді учням Звичайно є багато Ми
отримали відповіді учнів тому що
кількість здобувачів які прийняли участь
велика але Відповідно ми замітили що там
є такі запитання які скоротить уроки до
40 хвилин відповідно там зробіть блохи і
так дальше тобто є такі запитання які
можуть отримати аргументовані якісь
відповіді Ось і для батьків Також ми
додали такі запитання і відповідно коли
ми обговорили результати цього
опитування ми дійшли висновку до того що
потрібно змінити форму комунікації між
адміністрацією відповідно здобувачами
освіти тому що понеділка під час
планової години спілкування з
адміністрацією і здобувачів освіти Ми
будемо давати відповіді на ці основні
такі запитання які їх турбують так
відповідно на батьківських зборах Ми
також будемо давати відповіді на ті
запитання які торгують батьків тому що
дуже часто батьки або не хочуть
привертати для себе увагу або просто
бояться великої аудиторії ідуть додому з
вирішенням своїми проблемами ми
розуміємо що не можна зупинятися на
досягнутому учень до нас поступили
відповідно Вони мають якісь плани на
майбутнє Тому потрібно з ними працювати
так і в подальшому відповідно тут
получається такий у нас уже процес
скажемо підтримання їхньої охоти до
цього професії до цієї професії і тут
працює вже ціла команда зокрема цей
майстри виробничого навчання викладачі
роботодавця адміністрація і представники
центру кар'єри до якого у нас ходять і
бізнес-консультанти економісти і
професійні консультанти і відповідно
практичні психологи і кожна ланка тут
відіграє дуже важливу роль зокрема
викладачі майстрів виробничого навчання
вони їхня основна мета - це є створення
привабливої атмосфери так на уроці і
створення завзятості до навчання і
завжди на коли ми обговорюємо результати
навчальної діяльності Я говорю про те що
розумієте Якщо ваш урок він
перетворюється на суцільний монолог так
Або ж Для прикладу ви телепортується в
якусь лекційну залу попри те що ви
здійснити професійну підготовку на щось
ви робите Не те Так Значить потрібно
якусь змінити якийсь свій підхід до цієї
професійної етап діяльності відповідно
долучається адміністрація представники
учнівського самоврядування які працюють
над розвитком лідерських здібностей
роботодавці які на власній практиці
демонструють елементи професійного
такого успіху а також представники
центру кар'єри Також я завжди наголошую
і батькам наголошую при батьківських на
батьківських зборах на зустрічах
особливо на першій співбесіді про те що
ви розумієте людина третину свого життя
Вона проводить на роботі тобто невже ви
хочете про те що якщо ви Несвідомо
прийдете до вибору професії ви хочете
третину свого життя проводити ну зранку
Персонал це і говорити Ой знову я маєте
на ту роботу Звичайно що ні і плюс до
того ви знаєте що в нас є такі здобувачі
які просто обрали Цей заклад освіти тому
що це був єдиний можливий варіант і я
хочу сказати що тут також потрібно
Моя освіта Я є механік так і якщо би
мені на першому курсі задали це
запитання Чому я обрала саме цю професію
Я б також сказала що так склалися
обставини але я інженер-педагог
заступник директора Я дуже люблю свою
роботу і свій навчальний заклад І знаєте
що ще потрібно на нашу думку це задавати
собі запитання а чи хотіли би вас щоб
ваша дитина навчилася саме у вашому
навчальному закладі якщо ваша відповідь
ні то відповідно дайте собі запитання
Чому ні І це буде відповідно той фронт
змін Який необхідний вашому навчальному
закладі
Я знаю також що говорити про
профорієнтацію можна дуже багато я
більше впевнена про те що кожен
навчальний заклад має свій класний такий
дієвий кейс профорієнтаційної роботи але
я можу сказати що ми справді Стараємося
я можу сказати про те що Кожен працівник
нашого навчального закладу він є гордий
про те що він має змогу долучитися до
особистого зростання кожного нашого
здобувача освіту Я знаю що кожен
холодильник нашого навчального закладу
він в принципі щиро радіє що є причетним
до становлення їх як особистостей і як
такого потужного
кваліфікованого потенціалу нашої України
щиро вам дякую за увагу
вже Дякуємо дуже пані Світлана Дякуємо
за ваш цікавий дійсно актуальний досвід
який точно знадобиться всім адже
практика в соцмережах це є вже
необхідністю радше як окрема
інструментом тому дуже дякую вам ви
Можливо хтось має запитання
Окей дякую колеги тоді дякую пані
Світлана за ваш виступ ваша презентацію
І ті практики що ви впроваджуєте в
роботу
Ну а ми з вами продовжуємо працювати для
учасників хто з нами віддаленому форматі
підключається хотів би проговорити що ще
одна секція це буде Панельна дискусія
також буде транслюватися а в гібридному
форматі після того на нашій панелі
наживо Ми вирушаємо на перерву і на
подальші активності які вже на жаль не
зможемо покрити саме в онлайн форматі
саме з технічної сторони бо цей переїзд
і інші аспекти тож наша трансляція
триватиме до 13-ї години Так І після
того ми продовжимо формат наживо дещо
тож про наш наступний формат Що ми
будемо з вами Шановні колеги робити далі
як я вже я анонсував це є панель у
дискусія на тему особливості
профорієнтації для учнів молодшого
середнього та старшого віку тому що
стосується учнів зрозуміло ми з ними
точно працюємо в контексті
профорієнтації з тими хто вже здобуває в
нас освіту Ми знаємо що вони прийшли за
певним фахом ми для того працюємо ми для
того їм даємо поради розказуємо як саме
то може бути і має бути з нашого досвіду
досвіду нашого представників Так але ж
Нам необхідно нарощувати отой Континент
тих хто до нас вступає тих хто
зацікавлений в професійній освіті і
зрозуміло що це варто робити і треба
робити ще зі шкільних років і власне про
те як це правильно робити на різних
рівнях різних підходах ми трошки вже
бачили в презентаціях наших спікерів
першої частини ми ще от поговоримо прямо
зараз з нашими експертами панельної
дискусії і знову ж таки хотілось би за
можливість проводити такі заходи наживо
в комбінованому форматі А за підтримкою
ініціативи проектів подякувати нашим
експертам і зокрема організаціям
партнерів тим хто організував надав
можливість реалізувати проекти у фоскілс
- це країни Євросоюзу зокрема Німеччина
Польща Естонія та Фінляндія А це
Міністерство освіти науки України яке
разом з нами за проект реалізує Сьогодні
ми бачили і серед нас експерти
хамону тож Дякуємо за таку можливість і
продовжуємо працювати власне панель на
дискусія в нас теж в діджутальному
частковому форматі Я запрошую наших
спікерів двох ми з них вже бачимо на
екрані і Запрошуємо нашу спікерку
Наталію долучитися і зайняти місце поруч
зі мною так ось в такому форматі будемо
працювати Отже про особливості
проефорієнтації для учнів різного віку
ми будемо сьогодні говорити разом з
Мариною прошу вас сідати разом з Мариною
Діденко пічці в галузі психології
психологом-практиком з 12-річним
досвідом бізнес-трененко викладачкою
КНУКіМ авторкою науково-популярних
статей тренінгів онлайн-курсів експерт з
міт членів українського асоціації
організації психологів та психологів
праці вітаємо Марина бачимо у вас на
камері Добрий день
скажіть навчись Вітаю колеги рада бути
присутні сьогодні разом з вами хоча б в
такому форматі чудово вас чуємо
розуміємо радий навзаєм бачитися з нами
також на зв'язку Дмитро лобанов керівник
го потрібні тут директор центру розвитку
кар'єри Харківського національного
університету імені Каразіна в 11- 22-му
роках Дмитре Добрий день вітаю друзі
Вітаю Ради сьогодні бачити на жаль в
Харкові повітряні Вітрова тому буде
більше без мікрофону тому що дуже поряд
Сирена але підтримує всіх Дякую пропоную
розпочинати так Дмитро Бережіть себе
звісно безпека наш є пріоритет з нами
також наживо Наталія Попова заступник
директора з виховної роботи державного
навчального закладу запорізькі машину
будівельне вище професійне училище
Добрий день
а і з вами на дискусії ті в ролі
модератора Ну і Можливо трошки експерта
теж поділюся власним досвідом я Роман
Куриленко керівник відділ сприяння
працевлаштування та роботи з
випускниками КНУ імені Тараса Шевченка І
власне як пропонувати Дмитро ми будемо
розпочинати цю нашу панель Отже перше
наше запитання для мене воно взагалі
найголовніше пожитті А це запитання Чому
в контексті теми нашої дискусії вона
звучить так як мотивувати молодого
фахівця до розвитку тобто в чому аспект
ми розуміємо що знову ж таки старші діти
Вони вже знають що Працювати треба
працювати треба кимось орієнтується на
якісь професії Якщо ж ми говоримо про
учнів то на різному віці в них різні
цінності різні пріоритети загалом в ні
навчальному чи можливо ще й не
навчальному так і отже як їх на різних
етапах мотивувати як мотивувати загалом
саме учня що ще в школі Так про це
будемо говорити тут би я хотів до слова
першою запросити пані Марину
Дякую Роман
Так я якось думала що я потім включуся в
дискусії але Окей розпочну Шановні
колеги Шановні зібрання дуже рада що
сьогодні я тут особливо в такий важливий
час для нашої країни тому що саме Від
майбутнього покоління буде залежати якою
буде наша країна після перемоги і я
вважаю що дуже вчасно ми починаємо цю
дискусію звичайно дискусія про
профорієнтацію почалися давно і ведуться
ще з 90-х років і ми вже з вами багато
знаємо про те що має бути системність
має бути особистісно-орієнтований підхід
ми проводили багато досліджень і
кожні фахівці з різних галузей говорять
щось своє на що потрібно звернути увагу
і мені б хотілося сьогодні трішечки
знаєте іти не з можливо не З наукової
точки зору А більш з науково-практичної
так як я все-таки більш практик чим
науковиця і в мене є декілька тестів які
я б хотіла звернути увагу і пропоную вам
Потім зі мною по дискутувати або
погодитися або посперечатися наскільки
вам буде комфортно або наскільки
захочеться і перше на що мені хотілося б
звернути увагу коли ми говоримо з вами
про профорієнтацію молоді звичайно в нас
є особистості розвитку певного віку
провідна діяльність кожному вікові
мотиви і цінності але Мене зацікавила
думаючи про наше сьогодні дискусію така
теорія поколінь так звана яку придумали
американські вчені нею і Вільям Штраус
вони говорять про те що в залежності від
того до якого покоління ми з вами
відносимося в нас будуть певні цінності
і певні
мотиви Да те що нас буде з вами включати
і коли ми говоримо про сучасну молодь і
де мова про покоління Z або вже навіть
про покоління Альфа А ми з вами
представники попередніх поколінь там
Baby було мирів ігриків
відчувай і мислимо трішечки різними
категоріями разом з тими дітьми яких
яких ми з вами хочемо мотивувати і тому
для того щоб достукатися до дітей нам
потрібно зрозуміти А що є цінністю у них
що буде мотивувати їх і коли ми говоримо
про
те що цікаве для покоління Z це
покоління вже повністю інформаційних
технологій це діти які не навчалися або
не народжені без Інтернету вони не
знають цього світу без інтернету ну
незважаючи на ту ситуацію яка вона зараз
в країні коли повністю відсутній зв'язок
як наприклад зараз у мене я ледь знайшла
місце де є Інтернет Да В принципі вони
постійно знають що вони можуть щось
загуглити почитати до чогось звернутися
і покоління Z воно направлено на швидку
навичку яка зможе їм відразу дати
можливість заробляти гроші тобто якщо ми
хочемо говорити про мотивацію про те що
включать дітей Ми маємо показувати
чіткий зв'язок що ось ця навичка
особливо коли ми говоримо про про всех
освіти Ось ця навичка дасть тобі
можливість заробити ось це або зробити
Ось це І коли вони будуть бачити оцей
бонус від того що вони навчаються І як
це швидко буде на них впливати це буде
підвищувати їхню зацікавленість також
говорячи про техосвіту ми маємо
пам'ятати про те що Ну ще я знайшла
дослідження 2017 року я думаю що вже є
нові видання
каунтфанк медіа провели опитування
підлітків 13-17 років і з'ясували про те
що
підлітків вже підпрацьовують
майже 30% підлітків відпрацьовує або зі
своєї ініціативи або з ініціативи
батьків і їм
важливий оцей момент заробляння Тому
перше моя думка про те що ми маємо
показувати дітям як вони можуть заробити
Чому моя думка про те що все-таки коли
ми орієнтуємося на
мотивацію покоління Ми теж орієнтуємося
на певні цінності і нам треба зрозуміти
А що є цінністю тих дітей до кого ми
намагаємося достукатися Тому що тут
знову ж таки два моменти перший момент і
між ними така є прірва перший момент те
що діти бачать в соцмережах вони бачать
якісь творчі професії блогерство
богемне життя і другий момент особливо
коли ми говоримо про контингент
не знаю людей
середнього соціального рівня вони бачать
наприклад своє оточення своїх батьків
професій які мають їхні батьки або їхні
їхні сусіди або в містечку Да бо є ще й
регіональний компонент те що буде те на
чому працюють люди які проживають Тут у
мене І що дає їм можливість заробити і і
там уже немає оцього особистісного
компоненту Ми не задумуємося А що мені
цікаво є або те що я наслідую
бачачи своїх батьків а потім приходять
що в професію розчаровуюсь або взагалі
навіть приходячи ще навчання
розчаровують бо це не те що мені цікаво
або відірваність від того що я бачу в
інтернеті абсолютно те що немає
Прикладного характеру в масовості і
третє Моя думка з завершую і будемо
дискутувати це про те що ми звичайно
враховуємо особистісно-орієнтований
підхід зараз уже принаймні намагаємося
можливо не так системно як хотілося б
Але ми не враховуємо мотиваційні чинники
дитини і є багато досліджень про те а як
саме визначити що буде дитина мотивувати
не тільки в контексті зараз навчання А
мені здається що важливо розуміти що
буде мотивувати дитину і потім в її
роботі бо якщо ми знайдемо це класне
співвідношення інтере
мотиваційний чинник уже професійної
роботи то тоді в нас буде менше випадків
коли діти здобули навчання і
потім перекваліфіковується або не
працюють за професією бо на сьогодні
знову ж таки дослідження 2017 року ринку
праці показує що 50% людей не працюють
за професією яку здобули і скоріше
всього ідуть здобувати професію вже з
цією думкою
мотиваційні чинники можуть бути різні
наприклад можна звернутися до теорії
річа Мартіна про 11 мотиваційних
чинників і зрозуміти Да а що для дитини
буде важливо чи буде важливо колектив чи
кар'єрний ріст чи умови праці чи
соціально значущість
чи заробіток Да що для неї буде важливо
і провести оцю таку паралель А яка
професія чи який вид діяльності дасть їй
можливість реалізувати ці мотиваційні
чинники які є для неї важливо
швидко швидко Я вам протертирила Давайте
дистатувати
так Дякуємо дуже Марино І дійсно
хочеться дати думку можливо дійсно
подискутувати можливо підтримати
доповнити нашим наступним експертом
Дмитра Яка ваша думка з приводу того як
взагалі мотивувати молодого фахівця до
розвитку самого мотивації
Ну насправді Я підтримую тезу пані
Марина про те що прив'язка до грошей як
вони можуть заробляти і що саме от
конкретні навички дають певні кар'єрні
можливості та перспективи це я дуже
погоджуюсь і прямо завжди застосовував
свої робочі з молоддю і в рамках наших
от подій які ви проводили для секторів
розвитку кар'єру Ми також проговорювали
що це
дуже дієвий інструмент дуже дієвий
фактор який дозволяє
мотивувати і залучати молодь Разом з тим
хочу відзначити що ну потрібно дійсно
щоб ті навички які вони отримують все ж
таки призводили до того що вони можуть
тому що будемо веде Вони не зможуть це
реалізовувати на своєму своєму житті
тобто буде будемо отримувати зворотні
ефект також погоджуюсь Що дуже багато
зараз ми так трансляція всього тому що
бачу щось
супер тоді також Я
погоджуюсь Що залучати показувати те що
діти та Бульбашка яка формується в
Instagram в ті хто от всіх соціальних
мережах яких ми є
вона дійсно є всі ми навколо всіми
страждаємо від наших бульбашок Разом з
тим її той Фактор
залучення показувати
успішних людей успішне мотивацію з
різних професій як успішні рольові
моделі А І це також
дієвий інструмент Разом з тим розуміє що
в малих містах Вони завжди можуть бути
та кількість людей яких можна запросити
щоб вони могли провести цей захід якісно
щоб вони також володіли певними
навичками як виступити як презентувати
свою роботу
взагалі професію і перспективи чи
виявляє
підвисали Але можливо зараз зможете
спробуйте
тому такий короткий короткий коротка
історія
може бути
трошки переривається У вас зв’язок але
загалом зрозуміли тезу так тобто
фінансова мотивація теж є важливою так
дуже важливо але знову таки не єдиною і
власне про те Які ще можуть бути аспекти
саме мотиваційної складовою запрошую до
слова пані Наталя
Я хочу вам сказати що Запоріжжя - це
місцем міста Металургів У нас дуже
багато підприємств і тому здавалося В
нас немає ніякої проблеми для того щоб
обирати на навчання дітей але я хочу
сказати теж більше як практик тому що
заступник директор з виховної роботи а
профорієнтація належить саме в ній в
моїй компетенції тому хочу сказати
по-перше нам заважають стереотипи коли
на день відкритих дверей або будь-який
профорієнтаційний захід до нас приходить
школярі разом з класними керівниками ми
бачимо з якими обличчям вони приходять
ви розумієте вони такі зверхні от вони
приходять Вибачте не в заклад
професійно-технічної освіти вони
проходять в бурсу вони приходять в
царство тих людей які нічого не варті в
житті - це невдахи Це ті кому більше
нема куди іти і вони мотивують тих дітей
які приходять разом з ними Ну давайте
сходимо подивитеся і якщо ти не будеш
вчитися То ти прийдеш сюди
говорити і коли ми заходять то ми бачимо
Ці діти діти вони дивляться ось з такою
зверхністю жалюгідністю на нас і
по-перше для того щоб зламати цей
стереотип Ми беремо наших хлопців
красенів таких вони у нас одягають щоб
ми вони відрізнялися одягають такі
галстучки в нас є ці і вони проводять
екскурсії і Перше про що я ми говоримо
про те що тут не навчаються невдахи тут
навчаються діти які не розраховують на
мамин і папині гроші це діти які
приходять для того щоб заробити самі це
діти які не пішли у кримінал це діти які
мають руки які мають можливості які
мають голову і вони будуть працювати І
на навчання вони зароблять але зароблять
самі і їх треба за це поважати це діти
які були непотрібні у школі які їх
випустили Ну і сказали іди ради Бога і
всі а вони приходять до нас і у нас
цілий навчальний заклад таких
непотрібних людей скажемо так а вони у
нас і танцюють і співають і на
Всеукраїнських конкурсах і за м-м
займають перші місця і ми їм даємо нове
життя Ми відкриваємо їх як новий лист ми
не дивимося яким вони були в школі Да
останній там 9-10 ряду вони для нас
особистість ми вдихаємо в них нове життя
і вони розкривають цю Не зовсім
по-іншому тому я думаю що Вважаю
заважають нам стереотипи які ідуть іще
напевно зі школи коли вони отримують
робітничу професію то це не є покаранням
це є просто свідомим вибором це може іще
якісь шанс для того якщо от я сама
прийшла здавати документи коли ще була
після школи моя подруга здавала Ну мені
зробили таку гарну профорієнтацію я теж
здала туди документи я Токар я не
працювала жодного дня але я всім дітям
кажу Да я викладач українську мову
літературу зараз я заступник директора
але дітям Я кажу розумієте Сьогодні я
заступник директора викладач але от Хто
знав що буде війна да Ніхто не знав
Можливо я стану вимушено переміщеною
особою і оцей
оцей диплом дасть мені можливість
потрапити на завод і отримати робітничий
міст Можливо я не стану біля верстату
але я стану укладовку Я стану
розподільником роботи або ще це у мене є
запасний варіант Це мій шанс тому я
вважаю що перше це заважають стереотипи
друге це не підняття робітничої професії
у нас немає такого Ну як або
недостатньої кількості такого що
робітник чи професії - Це круто Це
престижно це класно цього нам не
вистачає У нас є зараз От дивіться
військові Да це круто зсушенки Там
пожежники
або лікарі Скільки в нас є фільми про
цих лікарів да е МастерШеф - це кухар А
ось про нас машинобудівне металургія у
нас нічого такого немає і нам потрібно
це розказати показати нам пощастило з
партнерами соціальними це у нас е-е
компанія групи Made Invest які проводять
з нами профорієнтаційну роботу вони
проводять дуже класно і дітей зі школи
Вони залучають от буквально перед війною
вони зробили такий квести Ну просто і
діти приходили вони в такій ігровій
формі вони це могли побачити що таке
Робітнича професія вони могли подивитися
включити виключити хоча б якесь уявлення
мати і також
акціонерне товариство Мотор Січ вони
разом з нами проводили профорієнтаційну
роботу вони
водили дітей на екскурсії на
підприємство для того щоб дитина коли
потрапила туди не
почала свідомість тому що це все ж таки
підприємство там є і великі верстати там
і шумно там може запах цієї ж емульсії
бути тому що як Ми розказуємо Ну то Ми
розказуємо так щоб дитина до нас прийшла
А коли вони потрапляють щоб Ой мамочки
Куди її потрапив для того щоб вона вже
щось бачила коли спочатку до нас
приходили учні наприклад там 7-8 класів
ми дуже-дуже ображались тому що нам
потрібно 10 9-11 а тепер Ми зрозуміли
добре що вони приходять розумієте вони
приходять ми показуємо не тільки
навчальний заклад ми вже проводимо і
квести ми проводимо майстер-класи ми
залучаємо там і показуємо яка в нас
самодіяльність і чим у нас діти
розумієте отака ну корпоративна культура
щоб вони розуміли тут чотири роки не
каторги а 4 роки цікавого життя
розумієте тому що ми робимо оте оте оте
і щоб їм було цікаво і я так вважаю що
все одно блогерство це швидкі гроші не
потрібно 4 роки навчатися розумієте ти
втік ток і зняв ось тобі грошики Капали
а тут потрібно вчитися тому от підняття
робітничих професій його Престижу а
також заробітна плата ви розумієте коли
хлопці приходять а у них низька
заробітна плата то звичайно вона будуть
їхати за кордон все дякую дуже Наталія
так бачиш бачимо особливо підтримку
ваших Тен Зая насправді теж долучаюся зі
своєї сторони підсумовуючої з власного
досвіду от я розказував на попередні
наші такі конференції що також викладаю
трошки стажкою літера його дійсно надати
їм розуміння ким саме ти будеш так і
надати їм розуміння що коли ти маєш
фахнути реально людина з таким особистим
певним професійним брендом і це не
дійсно важливо Це той бренд y який ви
кажете який варто розвивати показувати і
також коли представники закладу або з
виробництва приходять до них у школу
скажемо так чи коли вони приходять на
завод Це теж є дуже важлива мотиваційна
тому що коли нам кажуть ти будеш там
електрогазозварювальником з моторами
працювати це ну доволі абстрактно для
школи школяра золоті з відосика з
фотографією абстрактно так А коли
приходить приходить людина наживо коли
вона реально бачить Як це працює
формується Це дійсно інші емоції інша
мотивація тому підтримуєте за наших
спікерів власне от Мій досвід в
кар'єрному консультуванні теж про те що
показати це дуже-дуже сильні такі
мотиватор продовжуємо нашу дискусію і
наступне питання яке ми обговоримо воно
вже власне про профорієнтацію і про
сильні сторони власне про те як
визначити сильніший сторони
так Дмитра бачимо
Мені здається ми натрапили на дуже
цікаву думку що оце управління
очікуваннями у майбутніх наших учнів
студентів
у нас відбувається оце якраз можливо є
той важливий пункт чи є важливості на
яку ми можемо фокусуватися більше і саме
якщо казати про якийсь момент то мені
здається що ми можемо заглибитися саме в
те як ми на стадії профорієнтацію
управляємо Тімо очікування формуємо ці
очікування наших учнів майбутніх
абітурієнтів тому що потім якщо ми
сформуємо або занадто високі або занадто
низькі очікування оце
реальність може розбити
а ці очікування І саме На цьому з цього
моменту у нас починається величезні
проблеми що залишають професію залишають
демотивують і стають такими
позитивними амбасадорами профтеху а
навпаки негативне
негативними амбасадовим
не дуже позитивний фідбек дякую Мені
здається це дуже цікава думка яка у нас
з'явилась в рамках цієї розмови Так
дякую вам за цю думку дійсно корисна
інформація для обдумання нами І добре що
ми є підсвітили вдячний Дмитро вам за це
а наше друге запитання отже як визначити
сильні сторони та потреби нашого учня
Можливо якщо є необхідність
диференціювати на різних етапах середня
там молодша старша школа
прошу наших експертів до слова і зараз
запрошую Дмитра отже як визначити сильні
сторони наших учнів і можливо навіть
розказати про них щоб учні розуміли свою
сильні сторони то ми треба вам слово
так Дякую Ну можливо як визначити сильну
сторони то Мабуть це ж перевірено часом
Практика коли ми також насильно сторону
коли Наші учні кажуть Я наприклад маю
лідерські якості
найкраща історія що Путін привів 2-3
приклади для того щоб міг проілюструвати
якісь якості
як це як це якість чого проявляється і
Отже коли вони
розповідають про те що і мав досвід в
учнівському середовищі ми власне проект
був ініціатором волонтерська акція Отже
тут коли ми розмовляємо Тут також треба
вказати щоб
кар'єрного консультанта або фахівця з
профорієнтації повинна бути відповідна
кваліфікація і вже при розгляді
конкретних випадків акцентувати та
відмічати саме ті от сильні
сильні сторони та те що необхідно
покращити Мені здається що це дуже
простий але надзвичайно дієвий
інструмент в рамках якого Ми кажемо учні
розуміє що це треба Потрібно
підтверджувати Разом з тим на кожному
конкретному випадку ми можемо бо дуже
чітко показати А що ще через запитання
чи відкриття питання що Путін сам до
цього
відзначав цей момент
Дякуємо за вашу думку
чуємо Окей давайте рухатися далі колеги
Отже Хотів би запросити пані Наталю до
слова з вашим дійсно таким потужним
досвідом Як ви визначаєте сильні сторони
ваших учнів як їм доносити інформацію
про це ну ви знаєте мені здається без
психолога звичайно тут не обійдеться
тому що якщо
є діти коли вони приходять Вони знають
декілька професій От наприклад вони всі
хто у нас вони приходять вони всі
зварники і автослюсарі вони не знають що
таке крановій машиніст вони дуже не
розуміють що таке електрик вони цього не
розуміють тому що зварник - це і в
побуті це більш зрозуміло
процес розмови ми працюємо з ними ми
показуємо У нас є нам дуже пощастило У
нас є такий така кабіна
кабіна тренажер
кранівника І коли вони сідають туди
пробують але все ж таки
Тут повинен працювати і психолог і ви
знаєте буває так що От наприклад на
автослюсос нам потрібно 30 ми набрали 35
Да і оці 5 Ми не хочемо їх втрачати тому
ми проводимо переагітування і ви знаєте
коли буває так що ми попадаємо і він
вчиться і каже дуже добре а буває ті що
вони потім не хочуть ходити на заняття і
кажуть тому що я хотів бути тим то
тим-то тому я хочу сказати тут
як людина сама повинна вирішити знаєте
Як то казав Григорій славут Сковорода
йде сродної праці де ти чого тобі більше
хочеться І от Якщо ти будеш займатися
своєю любимою улюбленою справою там Ти
можеш реалізуватися найбільше не більше
користі принесеш суспільство я не можу
сказати що ми От так От діагностуємось
ми намагаємося А ось так без психолога
без виділення якості Ніяк Так дякую дуже
і повністю підтримую ми в своєму
практиці Ну я за фахом як знову ж таки
розказував повторююсь радіофізики дійсно
стикаючись з труднощами саме такою
психологічної експертизи але з нами
сьогодні на щастя на тій панельній
дискусії досвідчений психологія тож пані
Марина вам слово прошу тільки лаконічно
Дякую дивіться в чому проблема в тому
щоб психологи теж не вчать бути
профорієнтаторами і на сьогоднішній день
це І ми тоді знову ж повертаємося до
системної проблеми коли в нас мають бути
окремі фахівці з профорієнтації і тоді
вони вже мають визначати професійно
важливі якості але я б хотіла звернути
увагу на те що професійні важливі якості
не лише можна визначати які наявні у
дитини а їх можна розвивати і тоді ми
говоримо про те що ми в ми в процес
навчання або в процесі підготовки або в
процес агітації до вибору певної
професії можемо влаштовувати тренінги
майстер-класи які будуть вебінари які
будуть направлені саме на розвиток тієї
професійно важливої якості яка потрібна
дитині в майбутньому або там ну в
майбутньому фахівцю і дивитися наскільки
особистість гарно піддається до розвитку
цієї якості
так ця Дякую за вашу думку І дійсно те
Які взагалі навички має от наш учень
особистість уже на будь-якому етапі
кожен із нас є особистість так і те як
почути його як зрозуміти що от Той
досвід який можливо люди ще не
усвідомлюють що це вже досвід це вже
певна профілізація як це їм розказати
сказати що оце дійсно ваші сильні
сторони це важливе питання Ну і
сподіваюся трошки ми ближчими до його
розкриття стали і переходимо до
наступного питання нашої дискусії воно
звучить так як адаптувати підходи
відповідно до потреб цільової аудиторії
Ну і їх пріорітетів на от кожному рівні
Коли наш учень зростає змолоджую середню
школу старшу заклад професійного заклад
професійної освіти Так як же адаптувати
свої підходи оцих профорієнтацій
кар'єрного консультування давайте
зосередимось саме сьогодні на
профорієнтації Отже щодо цього питання
Хотів би запросити до слова пані Марину
знову
я знаєте Я сьогодні така як лише про
проблему кажу по-перше Питання в тому що
профорієнтацію в нас починається зі
старшої школи так як і європейська
практика показує про те що
профорієнтація має починатися з дитячого
садочку І ми тоді говоримо про те що вже
на етапі Ігор створення іграшок
створення мультиків ми вже зробили крок
до цього але ми маємо починати
показувати різні професії і готуючись до
нашої сьогоднішньої панелі Я знайшла вже
мультики які розповідають дійсно про
виробничі професії технічні які
показують дитині А
логіку Да що ось це ми робимо і це
призводить до цього що може викликати в
дитини інтерес яка в майбутньому захоче
теж стати частиною цього процесу
вироблення тому як ішла все-таки в нові
технології створювала певний
мультимедійний контент який
допомагає нам створювати оцю
профорієнтаційну діяльність саме
показуючи А яка професія в чому су
кожної професії і друге що потрібно
пам'ятати і теж дітям вкласти що на
даний момент професії змінюються дуже
швидко і виробничі в тому числі мають
певну специфіку да оновлюється
обладнання і потрібно буде там їхати на
перенавчання або не підвищення своєї
кваліфікації і здобуваючи одну професію
або одні якісь скіли чи навички ми
робимо тільки один крок а далі це як
знаєте як намисто далі ми будемо по
намистинці кожного разу нанизувати і вже
формувати себе як професіонала і ми
можемо так дітям і показувати що ось цю
навичку яку ти здобудеш далі ти можеш
розвивати в інших
аспектах і вийде Можливо щось абсолютно
цікаве абсолютно неординарне і ти зможеш
на прикладі якихось відомих людей і
клієнторів стати тим ким навіть сьогодні
не уявляєш так тому Ну можливо це про
мультимедійність
інфлюєнторів і показ
історії про те що говорила пані Наталя і
про те що професійна освіта - це крок і
він може бути кроком до чогось іншого І
наступного якщо ти захочеш так Дякую
дійсно дуже слушна думка і от мабуть
остання фраза теж дуже міська І якщо
людина хоче так тому що дійсно ми можемо
відкрити двері розказати
повідомити про можливості найширшим
чином так а от саме прийняте рішення має
власне наш учень наш здобувать пані
Наталія Яка ваша думка з приводу нашого
питання як адаптувати підходи відповідно
до пріоритетів наших учнів на різних
етапах Ну я погоджуюся з Мариною що
починати потрібно з молодшої школи коли
вони вже приходять до нас то ви знаєте
ми ще таку практику ми успішних людей
залучаємо тих які закінчили наш
навчальний заклад І ось із наших учнів
вони стали майстрами на заводах вони
стали начальниками цеху якого тобто
успішність просування кар'єри тому я так
думаю що
потрібно показати що і ми адаптуємо на
те що потрібно отримувати не тільки нашу
освіту після закінчення нашого
навчального закладу потрібно йти і
здобувати вищу освіту тому що ми
пояснюємо якщо ти закінчуєш наш
навчальний заклад ти є будеш зварником
дуже добрим зварником гарно
оплачувальним звернем але твоя кар'єра
вгору не піде якщо ти закінчиш вище
навчальний заклад То ти маєш ось таку
кар'єру нужно потрібно дітям все
розказувати показувати мотивувати і я
думаю все буде добре Так дякую вам дуже
за вашу думку і за ваш досвід від себе
також Ну я від себе власне Мабуть що
трошки повторюся бо вже проговорив це це
от дійсно інформувати консультувати
розказувати оцей весь такий шлях
розвитку тобто поступай до нас роби це
вивчай це і ось тобі такі то конкретний
результат тобто не просто зазвичай тому
що ти там на першому курсі чи вивчаю
тому що це в дев'ятому класі а для того
щоб так але от рішення ким буде має
залишатися за людиною це не дійсно
важливо для особистості тим більше чим
молодші Наші учні Тим більше вони оцю
самостійну стіну і ми маємо також
поважати оцю самостійність так поважати
іноді обережно тому що це все ще діти і
ми теж це маємо рахувати але поважати
так і от тоді знову ж таки такі такі
наші заходи профорієнтації будуть
успішними дієвами колеги в Дмитра дещо
переривається зв'язок тому ми будемо
власне завершувати цю панельну дискусію
саме в процесі спікерів якщо можливо є
якісь одне запитання то можна зараз
поставити
поки не бачу запитань тоді я дуже дякую
нашим спікерам хто був з нами наживо
пані Наталі Як так я дякую пані Марині
ще долучилася до нас паном дмитру який
знову ж таки незважаючи на реалії війни
науковий може знайти безпечне місце і
теж був з нами на зв'язку тож Дякую дуже
спікером дискусії зараз хочу подякувати
всім тим хто долучився до онлайн
трансляції адже знову ж таки незважаючи
на аспекти неможливості дістатися саме
сюди Так ви все одно з нами ви все одно
долучаєтесь дізнаєтесь ці можливості які
ви можете впроваджувати ваші практики і
профорієнтації з
учнями зі студентами залучати ваших
випускників залучати ще більше
роботодавців робити роботу своїх центрів
кар'єри ще ефективнішою для того щоб
професійно і професійно-технічна освіта
в Україні розвивалися набували нових
факторів нових показників популяризації
І от ми бачимо на позитивному досвіді
Рівненщини інших регіонів про те що це
працює ці от реформи ці міжнародні і
вітчизняні проекти маю свій результат І
власне Ми продовжуємо над тим працювати
Тому я дякую всім хто був з нами в
онлайні і
прошу вас також слідкувати за новинами
місцевих освіти і науки і долучатися ще
також хочу щоб ми всі разом зараз
подякували партнерам проекту А це
безпосередньо партнери проекти устілки
європейські Союз країні члени - це
Німеччина Польща Естонія Фінляндія А це
Міністерство освіти і науки України Так
Тож давайте разом подякуємо всім
партнерам
ну із учасниками хто був з нами онлайн І
кажемо До побачення і до нових зустрічей
до нових конференцій тож для учасників
онлайн Дякую що були з нами а і для